welcome everybody to the a slurry
podcast live here we are again thank you
so much for joining us thank you to
stitch fix clip expressvpn inaudible for
sponsoring this episode in here I sit
with you the finest men alive
the boys in fact more charitably or ant
lovingly yeah boys let's say lovingly I
like that I want to charitable I was you
take love yeah yeah yeah
anyway Jack films and the common
etiquette god bless them both and the
SOI board well I'm no expert on the
matter
I think boys my favorite insult like it
used to be Chuck you call people a [ __ ]
it's like and whether or not you think
it has any power you get called a [ __ ]
no I'm not
yeah the soy boys even funnier because
it's just like directly attacking your
testosterone levels you're just not a
man you are a soy boy who's got soy in
your veins and you don't eat meat now
what it's the so it's because you're a
vegetarian I thought it's because soy
makes your tits bigger that's it yeah
that's or decreases estrogen right so
he's got estrogen apparently has
estrogen in it
Wow that's these guys really know it's a
layered term yeah it's a lot going on is
it as popular as [ __ ] no like I don't
think so yeah it's honestly so it's been
on its way for a while the stock is
rising it's hard to genuinely insult
somebody with a phrase like soy boy yeah
it's somewhat jovial and thrilling I've
met more people who like this shirt for
the message of positivity and soy then I
have people who are like oh is it damask
you letting to heat soy sauce in these
guys eyes yes they're like [ __ ] soy
sauce I was like over indulges in soy
sauce and things was
not like you know well I mean that said
their cholesterol is probably gonna be
great because that's very high in sodium
that's right yeah it's a health thing it
might be a healthy out of them yeah Jack
how are you god bless welcome here thank
you thank you very um you're in the
Christmas spirit my dad what what makes
you say that even even your dog
the Christmas hat ception over here
Jack's bar I'm trying to get in the
spirit cuz I was talking with you a
little bit earlier just not in the
Christmas spirit yet and I don't know
what what that is because Christmas is
my favorite freaking holiday and I need
to like wake up and get in that
Christmas spirit I don't know if it's
like just because it's in LA but I mean
like that you've LA for eight years that
should be from and your previous
Christmases have been jolly very very
percent dully yeah I'm usually like
writing music and [ __ ] and now I'm just
kind of like so I'm trying to like
really get back in so what do you
think's going on why is this Christmas
the jolly levels are a bit lower than
previous years I don't know cause like
what back home we're watching all the
all the lifetime hallmark movies every
single one and like each one worse than
the one after it it's absurd but we're
doing that we got all the ornaments and
stuff do you guys get gifts to each
other where I think this year we're not
gonna do gifts we're just kind of over
the gifts thing but we usually do is
that part of the problem that's what it
is no he's like dude he's like dude it's
so much more than that
well what does it mean to be in the
Christmas spirit because I'm a young
Jewish boy Eric are you Jewish
no I'm I did I do Christmas but I'm I'm
with Jack I'm not feeling the spirit
right I thought you were a Jew can I say
that because you've got your name's milk
and your last name is all cut that out I
mean half the comments on my youtube
channel are people calling me that so
everyone gets it that's almost prevalent
it's soy boy yeah well they're all
comments do wanna you know combo so
explain to me a young sweet Jewish lad
yes what does it mean the Christmas
spirit because my dad has always been a
bit of a Grinch yeah he and Christmas
spirit was taken from me
it helped it helps if you just crank the
music out like as loud as you can in
every room you know you do that uh well
we have previously sometimes out just
like music yeah just like I like the
mannequin so let me tell you what's
Christmas oh it's a whole world okay oh
it's lovely
I think I might get a second Israel like
the Hava Nagila that stuff is not cool
that's because they didn't do an
electric violin version of it for like a
Sears commercial oh that would help that
thing has been playing for like 20 years
trans-siberian Orchestra styling what it
is just kind of like a control [ __ ] is
that the band that does it though it's
like I so I always get them confused
trans-siberian Orchestra and then
there's another one and I'm sure you
people guys online you know I'm talking
about get it mixed up but they were both
like very since heavy you know that one
is transfer burns you nailed it
trans-siberian okay yeah and that's like
they do this you know very MIDI carol of
the bells and that's where they have
like the electric guitar yeah I feel
like you're getting in the Christmas
spirit
well you see okay you have it and I
don't know Arirang no I don't because
when I hear Christmas music on the radio
I angry because I swear to God because
like my favorite station is like I
listen to all these on the radio and
then when in November when like yeah
November after Thanksgiving all the way
through the new year it's the same
freaking Christmas music and I want to
get I don't want to hear that [ __ ]
I want to hear actual music that I want
here it's just once a year
yeah swallowed up just one month of the
year it's like one twelfth of my whole
year doctor right it was a whole bit
earlier they pick it up a little bit
like they've got a figure they think
doing Christmas Lanka but there is I
think Hanukkah music is neglected I mean
Paul McCartney never wrote a Hanukkah I
mean everybody on the Christmas I'm
digging into my own my rolodex surprised
me Chris right no peeling that barn you
out a serious song what's that really
famous one he didn't write Hanukkah song
he did write a Christmas famous we
yeah and that one it's I'm gonna claim
just for humming it I love Paul
McCartney Paul McCartney i sir - you
cringe
he is knighted but that song sucks I'm
sorry yeah Wow Paul McCartney but that
just clone - Paul McCartney's we're not
the bullet bourbon boys oh yeah just
gonna take like hot swings out of that
thing what do you want you guys want can
we get some glasses in here for the boys
please oh thank you just gonna hit that
dance and your imagine it I'm intrigued
though by your your having what seems to
be an existential crisis in your life
yeah yeah it just just lack of I just
I'm just in a weird I'm in weird shape
right now it's the Christmas thing it's
a whole creativity thing you know
burnout but it's just it's just figuring
out and so mmm I mean sure I've been
through this am I in my personal life so
many times in my career in YouTube but
I'm fascinated by it
it's kind of a self feeding cycle in a
sense are you getting negative comments
from your fans is that feeding it or
like or are they supportive there
they've lately they've been extremely
supportive very thankful for that and
they just they've been giving me some
pretty solid constructive criticism in
the past just because my videos I've
just been very stagnant in quantity or a
quality I should say is that part of the
issue for you and then knowing that is
the issue for me yeah just like how do I
get out of this rut cuz all my videos
are like a month ago all my videos were
the same and I hated where I was at and
so it's like I don't like get out of
there
so I'm trying new stuff and getting back
in the groove slowly but it you know
it's not perfect I'm fighting it what
what do you do when you're in a rut I
was when I'm gonna run yeah I was gonna
say I run I don't know what to do oh no
I'm not what's the opposite of a role
you know I'm in a role yeah in a role
you're I'm gonna roll down the hill my
help
one fire you're never in a [ __ ]
towards a rut you know you don't roast
enough to be in a rod no that's true I
guess I would help sir I guess that
would help but why don't you you're not
gonna post more that will not happen
well I don't I think in my leading you
know what would what would help that
along is if I had like a studio so right
now I film everything in my room right
but if I had like a dedicated space I
could go to and film things in hmmm I
just like overthink [ __ ] before I start
filming it which would not give like a
place would that give you incentive yeah
like get out of bed and you know the
work is so weird like because I wake up
and then oh that's where I'm going all
day my point it's just my chair
recreation and work is your personal
life this isn't my bed anymore this is
my tripod yeah I used to be in New York
it was really rough like it's your
living room your bedroom your work room
you're everything it's nicely one tiny
yeah yeah but you got AC in there I
believe I do
finally a but I only got AC but I'm
never gonna use it too offensive or what
no I just like being sweaty I'll use it
when I'm editing yeah but I will say
Jack the Will Smith fit you made well
yeah fantastic thank you for comments
were great everyone was very happy that
was submit you feel jolly absolutely
that put me in the Christmas spirit
right away that certainly certainly
helped no that was great like seeing the
feedback like oh so many comments were
like the old Jack is back and that's to
me that's the highest praise because
that's where I'm trying to get back to
UM times I'm wonder if that's like
because I've been there people haven't
telling me they miss the oldies and
forever but it's like tasting the drag
that I hate hearing that even when it's
in a good way
because right they mean the best but
it's still a thing yeah it's a
double-edged compliment you don't wanna
you need to you just it's hard not to
look back but you kind of have to not
yeah you shouldn't it I think it's a and
B because well first off senses of humor
do evolve over time and [ __ ] I found
funny five years ago even two years ago
I don't find funny now or I find it
funny in a different way hmm I do feel
like sometimes I I got to go back and
the archives and figure out what was I
doing back then that was that I just
wouldn't even think of sometimes it's
like that's where he gets well we know
what it was yeah I find when I look back
on my old videos it's not so much that
like I was doing something it's just
it's really about the state of mind yeah
because you're in a healthy place in
your mind you doubt yourself less you
question yourself less and you're when
you're I find that when I'm in a better
headspace I'm always making better stuff
so I found that it's very much about how
I'm feeling rather than something
specifically I'm doing you kind of like
just fearlessly just like making [ __ ]
moving on yeah I like that I like that I
I just get in these like that's a good
way to put it because I do I paced
around the house like all day it's just
it's it's sad are you just trying to
think of ideas yeah and I'm talking to
myself fleshing out ideas and jokes is
this funny will this work and yeah being
in the right state of mind I think would
work wonders are you in therapy I am not
in therapy personally but army it's been
huge yeah because I've been in a rut and
I always thought of therapy as some like
I was like dude [ __ ] it and smell your
own [ __ ] why were out at therapy but
I swear to God
it's helped me a lot and I think it
actually helped me get out of my rut
because there's so much other [ __ ] going
on it's it's hard to it's really so hard
to step out of yourself and see what's
the actual problem so all the times the
real problem is not something that you
are addressing or even aware of and that
honestly has been really valuable to me
how once a week twice yeah I go once a
week he tells me I need to come twice a
week but he's like you really ought to
come twice a week you're [ __ ] up need
your therapy are you have it's great
you're cured you know it's like it's
like pausing your Netflix subscription
[Laughter]
yeah there shouldn't be a stigma about
therapy even though that you know people
like to put one there just because it's
like well I'm not going to one so I must
be good then a week later like their
grandma dies and
like you might want to unravel that yeah
yarn yeah are you how is there a reason
you haven't considered therapy or you
just felt like you haven't needed it you
know I guess the latter I've just never
put much the thought into it it's not
that I don't believe in it because I
absolutely would do me good it's just
one of those I just haven't pursued it
because it's a whole thing
it's a whole thing yeah and I I'm not
and I'm not knocking it I'm sure I could
I could absolutely benefit from it I
just I don't know I feel like I gotta
figure I don't know I say I got to
figure it out but I know therapy would
help me well the thing is I was stuck in
a rut for so long
and I was I was just I was like super
irritable and I was super just like like
I was always trying to get out of it and
run and run and run and I was just
running like in a hamster wheel I don't
know if this is your situation I'm
totally on my own person but I felt like
I was in a hamster wheel for like a
whole year just right I was getting
worse and worse and worse
yeah and so I just had like a breaking
point where I started taking medicine
and started going to therapy and I think
that was like three months ago but I
tell you life-changing that's fantastic
man I guess I mean what was the stories
we miss coming on the show actually I
hear I'm laughing back I love that one
okay yes the last time I went to him
he's like I really think you should come
twice a week don't it's too much yeah
you gotta push down somewhere yeah Wow
holy so I'm not supposed to drink
alcohol but I'm also don't wanna be a
Grinch well either definitely can't
drink all guys she's got a bun in the
middle of and you're not drinking she's
not drinking I'm not drinking that's my
cuz apparently on antidepressants you're
not supposed to drink alcohol but does
anyone really care about that I
apologize
well here's me and Jax therapy bad luck
did not Cheers another alcohol drink
yeah
I know so pregnant women yeah look
something I just avoid ladders that's
all I'm gonna say
okay wait who curse - did I curse you or
did you curse me well I have the alcohol
so I think you I think all right you
guys wanna watch some video some [ __ ]
enough for this uh show me them videos
yeah what's that what's good on the
what's good on the boob tube man have
you seen YouTube rewind hmm YouTube
rewind what's that okay yep actually I
haven't seen that I okay so I think yeah
what the [ __ ] is in there for me do we
watch together is that old news mmm
I feel like everybody might you want my
password I mean we can get Eric's live
reaction are you through that's pretty
special
oh just be staring into this camera like
it's the office the whole yeah oh I do
want to make a couple announcements
before we proceed Tuesday's our big
annual charity stream with Justin
roiland
Alex Hirsch we've got it bigger and
badder than ever so and also post Malone
is donating a smash guitar signed for
the raffle as well as many other items
Joey salads is here he's gonna eat
progressively hotter peppers at every
milestone we have a little kiddie pool
full of milk he's gonna put on a life
vest little rubber duckies and a whole
scuba gear sit in a pool of milk and eat
progressively hotter peppers all the way
up to Carolina Reaper and I think we
should know he's flying in for this yeah
this is a big event this is huge can I
be the set medic also on Friday we want
to do the best and worst of the h3
podcast it's gonna be it's gonna be
rough send your submissions to podcast
at HBO reproductions calm for your best
and worst so let's skip let's skip
YouTube rewind let's uh oh this is
amazing so this year you guys are gonna
this is amazing
Mark Wahlberg you know it's funny to see
Mark these days cuz we saw him recently
in a in a movie with Tom
Segura was in that movie the instant
family and it's a great movie and it's
such a wholesome fun and he's got this
wholesome vibe now mm-hmm but here's
Mark back in the ninth like real goofy
pretty boy listen how he talks he throws
on like an accent oh I think he dropped
some wine in here that is will become
iconic goes out to my man Calvin Klein
good looking out for the drawers not
saying I would do another Fruit of the
Loom commercial or nothing like that cuz
they don't make the hype shorts these
these are the nineties man they just fit
good and they hold hold me snug so I'm
about to go get some skins I'm not gonna
put on like no silk underwear oh she's
got freckles it's like a YouTube
prankster who she got freckles
she got freckles wait it gets better
there's no music I definitely got like a
sock in his pants look at that lump
looks like he's got a big one you think
you know yeah not that big it looks like
an eggplant
that's crosses a [ __ ] look at that
shudder I don't think it's supposed to
fit like a diaper dude [ __ ] Mount
Vesuvius though man but here we go
the real it's what they removed the
music to make it awkward
alright this is this really the 90s
that's just how they did it yeah my
money on mark this is real yeah like a
real lack yes oh and here comes no the
best protection against aids just to
keep the Cowan's on that's protected
against AIDS
keep your Calvin's on well does that
mean if he puts his dick through the
hole then here doesn't get AIDS maybe
it's the kind that doesn't separate you
know that's there's so many things wrong
right well yeah sure we can unpack
mostly you could still get AIDS with
those on I guarantee you like the AIDS
scare of the 90s yourself [ __ ]
underwear go you got put on your couch
your baby let me [ __ ] you through my
Calvin's
full body Calvin's best way to prevent
AIDS is heat it on your couch
I guess he's saying is he promoting
celibacy is that what he's doing what is
that like not having sex keeping his
undies like flirting with her yeah yeah
right so the message doesn't make sense
because he's absolutely promoting
celibacy and yet at the same time he
just wants a hand guy yeah that's the
line they cut out at the end this way to
prevent AIDS get a hand guy I'm Martin
Martin oh another take okay oh okay that
wasn't that was you know like what is
Nancy Reagan need me to say right
seriously or wait who was it that was
cuz guys remember like in sex ed every
time it was like okay here's the
different steps of protection you can
take but really don't have sex right
absolutely
what's the congregation I'm I had some
wild lessons and sex ed did you guys
like I had one teacher I had a lot of
conservative teachers I don't know why
one teacher had told our whole class
straight up she said guys women do not
enjoy sex I'm telling you right now the
female orgasm is a myth whoa
doctor told her whole father she's like
women do not enjoy sex and I had watched
a lot of porn in my life by then and I
was like that is not the impression I
got I know porn over sells it but I was
really comma ties because I was like
whoa like what a terrible forget it yeah
so just you know get yours all right I
mean I guess her point was that you put
it into make a baby and then you take it
out right she got that across it was it
the abstinence yeah that was what they
always called it in sex ed I went to he
abstinent Catholic middle school and
that was absolutely all they tell you
about condoms at all they did but they
were heavily frowned upon just just
don't do like if you absolutely have to
sin yes
they put like fish hooks through it is
how they come yeah we call it these are
condoms aka Satan's hand
Satan's mouth right they heat up real
hot they burn you and the only other 50%
success rate yes don't
try children we call these Satan's
butthole it's like putting your dick and
Satan's butthole when he put a condom on
he was great he's there what was sex had
like in Israel it was like what they
teach you and I mean not like a one time
session they're just like here we go
guys person someone would come like not
the teacher someone else would come they
demonstrate and oh yeah it's like
straight out of like freaks and cakes
yeah I don't really remember it was very
short and everyone was feeling awkward
yeah I remember they showed us gnarly
pictures of like STD ridden penises
really that oh yeah like an unbelievable
overhead projector yeah there were like
real pictures like a penis like the only
way can describe it is like a lion's
mane of chlamydia there were always the
illustrations not good
we only got a yeah if it was we got
illustrations Jack would be in the
Christmas spirit clear with the sitch
the situation i know ii ii ii touch yeah
so what about the celibacy yeah yeah of
course there I'm sorry of the situation
yeah well so it was a sweet message cuz
you had on one hand what's her name the
girl who ran with McCain Bristol Palin
yeah Sarah Palin's daughter who has like
three kids at a wedlock advocating for
celibacy and then then uh she might
actuator get it like that might get
people to be celibate I mean you're a
hypocrite but don't go let's see these
we may have watched it on the podcast so
we have washing you did a long time ago
yeah yeah you guys know that if he'd
call Mark Wahlberg Marky Mark he gets
really mad no I didn't like that oh
really
but that should be like a term of
endearment like what it's a nickname I
think it's like a rebranding thing he's
just like oh shot
I named ed by the way you know when he
was young he like beat the [ __ ] of a
Chinese guy blind yeah gotten a lot of
trouble made some dude blind right I
don't I think he's like he's handled
that by just like burying it but like it
keeps coming up every couple of years on
reddit really today I learned Marky Mark
nearly killed the guys did you know he's
the one with the crazy schedule right
yeah I'll stir it out mister 3:00 a.m.
yeah I don't get you don't have to wake
up at 3:00 a.m. that doesn't impress me
you can wake up at 6:00 a.m. and still
do as much what's up what was his
bedtime if you woke up at 3:00 we watch
that let's watch that it's not an actor
watch take a picture of his schedule oh
I thought he had a video talking James
Corden in a bit with him they like he I
think the host James Gordon tried to
like live a life live a day in the life
of Mark Wahlberg via that's really old
sketch I hear ya it's like I'm trending
[ __ ] morning well that's just not
that's not admirable that's just that's
lunacy yeah these vanity is what it is
and what time do you go to bed when you
wake up at 3:00 and kids and shake it's
eight you don't live a life if you only
go to eight really you don't you work
anywhere today I mean like I don't
believe that this is a daily schedule
for the guy maybe when he's like Mark
Wahlberg's insane workout schedule
starts at 2:30 in the morning
that's ridiculous is this guy's
superhuman well no he just goes to bed
at 8:00 like a [ __ ] nine-year-old
what up what a nerd what a pointer busy
he goes to bed at 7:30 ela correct the
record imagine going to bed at 7:30 oh
my god imagine being famous and wealthy
and achieving everything you ever wanted
in life and going to bed at 7:30
doesn't that undermine elf success my
night doesn't start to like 10:00 that's
the picture of the schedule typical
daily schedule cryo chamber I'm sorry
that was the first thing that cryo
chamber recalled well that's the secret
right right it's prayer time bateman
nine to 45 SCOTUS thank God
he prays for 30 minutes that's a that's
a hell of a prayer man he's got a rosary
and a half God please don't let me get
in more trouble for that [ __ ] please
Jesus
please don't anyone call me Marky Mark
today drop dead
I'll make him blind dear Lord
post-workout meal shower golf this
[ __ ] got time to pray and golf
okay but to be fair got nobody calls for
30 minutes you think he's whacking off
something else probably got a little tea
maybe like a little green driving range
or something yeah yeah it's nap time
meaning golf at home he's got 30 minutes
for a snack what a cutie pie what is he
like a boss the juice and some crackers
no no no that's wrong he has an hour and
a half of snack time
our oh my god it's 90 minutes boys
allocate that time more to golfers and
then he has another snack immediately
after that so he's just snacking living
it up he's definitely snacking in the
cryo chamber like what else do you do in
there is in there for an hour yeah look
at this 11:00 a.m. family time it's like
all right everybody gather up get around
we got one hour
well well y'all so careful he also has a
sandwich in meetings and work calls so
it's family time but he's on the phone
the whole time they don't even get their
own hour yeah but everybody let's take
an hour for lunch
yes Marky Mark he's like okay everybody
they've lunch that we've made fun of a
lot of people the four of us when we're
all together but this is the first time
I've been afraid that like they're gonna
kick this [ __ ] door down and just
blind in one eye but you guys are making
jokes about me huh boys you see Planet
of the Apes I heard you guys were mean
he's got kind of a Mike Tyson thing with
the realsense there was I heard you guys
were making jokes about me I just want
to tell you he has like the sense even I
just want to tell you guys across that
it's not cool that you guys making fun
of me he looks like he's always
explaining to a kid why they can't buy a
present Wow
really accurate I just don't get that
right right no it's like your mom's
gonna see you come back with it she's
completely mad
[Laughter]
can I say something go I actually loved
that shtick
I'm very charmed by it yeah the sick
being white his voice no his like
sensitive tough guy I love that
character I worked on a movie that he
was in oh yeah
tell me about the experience it was the
lovely bones the loveliest lovely bones
yeah I was like a an additional PA crew
member a swing guy in there somewhere
like a weekend but I got to see him
walking around set I'll tell you he's
always in a good mood he was whistling
singing no cup of coffee in his hand
just bopping along like the little swing
really got a stain on it I really should
have gotten this thing dry clean before
the stain does not come with I don't
think you need to dryclean that I mean
so I so positive he probably goes in his
trailer and like punches someone in the
face yeah I lied you warned me about
like eye contact or anything like that
they'd hear about with celebrities but
right right just looking back that's a
weird that's weird require oh don't make
eye contact like there's stories about
that's appear insanity really super good
actor who liked it Lincoln what's his
name Daniel day-lewis no eye contact no
the opposite eye contact only then like
the best actor wouldn't need that for
like his method acting it's like I get
it you look him in the eyes he [ __ ] up
his character [ __ ] but he was like
between takes on Lincoln just like
chillin with the crew and like telling
stories and stuff in there you go
alright no just out of character oh [ __ ]
I was like alright let's go again I'm
Lincoln Wow maybe they thought good he
is better Pro it makes me doubt the
whole eye contact thing that it's like a
performance issue oh yeah there's actors
being divas the whole point what do I
know I'm just well I sorta mean I don't
allow you to look me in the eye
yeah but that's like
yeah I'm just like whoa in careful with
that I contacted I already warned you
twice you just like alright we're gonna
take a break
fans yelling at me guys we're gonna take
a quick break we'll be right back the
boys are just back in town and we're
only beginning we've only watched like
one video of rigging a hundred thousand
that's right we'll be right back stitch
fix is an online personal styling
service that finds and delivers clothes
shoes and accessories to fit your body
budget and lifestyle now Dan's got a
sweater he got from them that he frankly
has never taken off and it looks good on
him it's like they read your mind and
said hey this is the perfect sweater for
Dan dan would you agree yes or no
absolutely there it is folks this is how
it works you go to their website you
take a survey about your style they show
you pictures of clothing to rate how you
like it to figure out your style so they
have a good idea what you like you just
go to stitch Vic's calm /hre tell them
your sizes what you like how much you
want to spend and boom Bob's your uncle
you get some awesome clothes in the mail
you'll be paired with your very own
personal stylist will handpick items to
send right to your door you try them on
you only pay for what you love you
return the rest shipping exchanges and
returns are always free my dude so
there's no subscription required you can
sign up to receive scheduled shipments
or get your fix whenever you want
styling fees are only 20 bucks and it's
applied towards anything you keep from
your shipment so it's pretty much free
here's what we're doing get started
right freaking now at stitch fix calm
slash h3 and you'll get 25% off when you
keep all items in your box that's stitch
fix calm slash h3 to get started today
stitch stitch fix dot-com / h3
here is the last toothbrush you will
ever need
it's quick it's a perfect Christmas gift
it's high-tech but at an affordable
price this is an amazing electric
toothbrush
it's got soft perfect bristles because
gums are sensitive and you do not want
to damage your gums because let me tell
you about gums folks they do not grow
back and you're gonna find that out
later in life ring be like dammit I wish
I'd listened to Ethan and gotta quit not
only that it tells you when to switch
sites so it vibrates vibrates vibrates
OH
30 seconds switch sizes so you know and
it turns off when you're done so you
always get the perfect dentist
recommended brush this is my favorite
toothbrush I will not use any other
toothbrush it's also got a tongue
scraper on the back so you can get all
that nasty [ __ ] on your off your tongue
and have that beautiful kissable breath
and beautiful teeth and mouth that you
deserve goddamn it because let me be
frank and square with you all there's
nothing nothing nothing worse than a
disgusting mouth that's it if I smell
your breath
if I see you don't take good care of
your teeth I'm out right ela as a girl
yeah I meant so here that's why I love
quip and they've got over 5000 verified
five-star reviews to back it up alright
so it starts at only 25 bucks what go to
get quote comm /h through right now you
get your first refill pack for free with
a quick electric toothbrush but you
don't have to tell your gift T that well
not that big video they're like well
don't tell them I got the refill for
free
that's your but it is a hookup that's
your first refill pack free at GE tqu I
p.com slash age with all the recent news
about online security breaches it's hard
not to worry about where my data goes
make an online purchase or simply access
your email could put your private
information at risk you're being tracked
online all the time by social media
sites marketing companies and your
mobile and internet provider that's why
you need to take your internet privacy
back right now use an express VPN
expressvpn has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of any
computer phone and tablet turning on
expressvpn protects protection only
takes one click I'll tell you what takes
more than one click trying to get your
identity and your data back after it's
lost try getting back your credit card
your stolen credit card information and
the money that people
off after yeah that's more than one
click to one click now expressvpn
secures in anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address protect
yourself with expressvpn cost less than
seven dollars a month protect yourself
online to date and find out how you can
get three months free at expressvpn comm
/ H Street that's expr e SS VPN comm /
h3 for three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn comm / h3 to
learn more what would it look like if we
all listened more well listening to
audiobooks motivates inspire us us and
even brings us closer together and if
you recall I asked Jordan Pearson our
audiobooks as good as reading and he
said yes of course I wondered that
they're just as good baby
even better and I'll tell you why you
can multitask you can exercise you can
game you can even sleep I don't know how
much you'll absorb but you can do that
and audiobooks are good for any activity
whatever it is enhancing it makes it
better for our audience audible is
offering a free audiobook when you start
a 30-day trial so you got no risk baby
just give it a shot if you want to
listen to it audibles got it just go to
audible.com slash h3 podcast or text h3
podcast - 500 500 and browse their
unmatched selection of audio content
start your 30-day trial download an
audiobook for free and start listening
it's that easy there's no better place
to listen then audio then audible
because now audible gives members even
more exclusive audio fitness programs
and audiobooks audible originals and
more and now with audible originals you
can experience even more custom content
made exclusive for audible members
here's the stuff that I get into on
audible they've got all of the Lord of
Rings trilogy they've got all of the
Harry Potter's they've got all of the
Game of Thrones they've got all of the
best sagas and series like that and
you've just got so many hours of great
content acted out narrated by incredible
actors you got to give any one of these
series if you're interested in you're
gonna love it
over at audible every month as audible
as an audible member you get one credit
good for any audiobook you choose plus
two audible originals from a changing
selection you can't get anywhere else
audible members also get access
the audio fitness and health workouts
created exclusively for audible plus
your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and re-listen
anytime even if you cancel your
membership they don't like your
audiobook exchange it no questions asked
so here's the offer guys start a 30-day
trial and your first audio book is free
go to audible.com slash h3 podcast or
text h3 podcasts to 500 500 that's a UD
IB le dot-com slash a stream podcast or
text h3 podcast to 500 500 we are back
welcome how was the break for you guys
you've all enjoyed yourselves and it was
a really nice break I didn't want it
yeah actually I brought my switch if we
could just play a little smash for a
couple of hours wait so what is being in
someone's eye line mean because that
doesn't even sound like we making eye
contact but just be in there filming and
like you know like this camera right
here if there's somebody standing like
to the left of it you're like kind of
you know drawn to them like you want to
look at you and you're so it's while
you're acting it's anybody that walks in
the back and it's kind of like it makes
your eyes jiggle a little bit it's kind
of weird but like at the same time it's
very easy to your professional yeah that
just ruins the illusion though I mean
nobody's standing next to a camera like
in the case of you know some diva that
wants that kind of [ __ ] nobody say next
to the camera going like this [ __ ] up
come on
I wonder I'll be like II look it out of
my eye line yeah holding the camera
let's see Google's CEO went before
Congress and one member of Commerce
Congress what was his name Larry [ __ ]
old as hell heard this is the iPhone guy
yeah what's his name
I believe Steve King Steve King pizza or
no no relation he has this question for
the CEO one of the most powerful men in
the world really come before Congress
humble
himself before our government and this
is the question that our best and
brightest elected officials have for the
CEO of Google I have a seven-year-old
granddaughter who picked up her phone
before the election and she's playing a
little game kind of game a kid would
play and up on there pops a picture of
her grandfather and I'm not going to say
into their record what the kind of
language was used around that picture of
her grandfather but I'd ask you how does
that show up on a seven-year-olds iPhone
who's playing a kids game
congressman iPhone is made by a
different company and so you know I mean
I might have been an Android
I was just it was a hand-me-down of some
kind you know wait there's a live
question I'm happy you can do that I
think she's a female because she we've
seen I've seen her I believe it's the
same person she was at something else
another hearing another congressional
hearing where she dressed up in the
exact same attire adjusted the monocle
it's that easy to get in there well I
don't know how he's open to the public
I think the public hearing come in later
if I had to guess I would say the
mustache wasn't on oh you mean they
entered I I disagree a sorrowful
statement now and that she got a prime
location to it like immediately caught
my eye when the guy was like answer the
question I've watched this video several
times and now I'm just noticing this
person the guy's dribbling a basketball
but there's a girl at walking in the
background oh yeah so let's continue
we're almost more Legation which was
being used which had a designation but
I'm happy to understand it better and
clarify it for you okay thank you for
your testimony and yield back the
balance that comes sorry picture of of
him I guess he said of her grandpa came
up on her phone now how does that happen
on
my phone he's like well I'm max from
Google first of all yeah I think we have
to take into consideration this guy
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
well yeah yeah but like imagine you've
got this guy historically powerful
person and you're throwing this don't
like even if it was the wrong company
just imagine ask him like why is there
why is this picture on my phone how
could that happen why are people making
fun of me yeah anytime online of all
places yeah there's a little there's a
couple of flaws to his laws yeah
Oh Danny not ever use the Internet
apparently well no and I think that's a
big problem with our government is that
it's run by a bunch of old [ __ ] who are
still using AOL comm and they're trying
to fix like global warming and right
hold on baby let me uh let me dial up
real quick and check the science
yeah well says it's all good I got a few
more free hours left hold on baby I'm
like hold on baby I'm waiting for my my
CD in the mail yeah I just I just got
thirty three hours right this guy in
this chatroom said there's nothing to
worry about
yeah Dale's all he says it's all good
you know I read something and it may be
a total [ __ ] but it makes sense that
there's still millions of people paying
AOL dial-up to this day okay let's break
that down
millions of people where are these in
the States we're gathered throughout the
states I'm gonna get some Florida you
know what Florida is a Florida man
probably Florida grandma Florida grandma
I wouldn't be surprised if my
grandparents were still paying aol.com
can you imagine that's like that's
amazing
how did like how would they learn though
to upgrade to not dial-up you know so
they learn presumably grandson better
than me I'm justifying their their no
use yeah no their their fault effusion
Wow confuse Monteux there they are
faultless because they didn't even
understand it when it came out back then
they're old right now there's we picked
that up pretty quickly yeah so like you
know we've we've got that that is our
responsibility like you know they're
supposed to not kill the environment
leave us some [ __ ] money for our
retirement funds all we have to do is is
plug their computers into it a new one
they can get their emails and I had it
viruses twice as fast that's true
wait they shouldn't have fast internet
that's a really good point because
there's a huge problem of people preying
on old people and gaming money someone
called my grandma once and said
impersonated me they had all my
information when I was in college it was
before I was known to anybody and they
say hey it's Ethan I probably didn't
sell anything likely but she's old as
[ __ ] on a landline they says hey it's
Ethan I'm trapped in Mexico and I'm
arrested and I need you to send me five
thousand dollars bail and she was gonna
do it and my brother was there luckily
and stopped there that's awful but like
apparently I saw like it's a billion
dollar business just scamming old people
yeah that's so sad there's fake IRS
calls that are really getting a lot of
attention these days they're all from
India oh we had our IRS so you pay now
yeah I don't know there was like a voice
modulator they made them sound like
there were some like southern
good-old-boy they would get so much more
why am i giving them ideas to pick up on
that they're gonna start taking like
southern Japanese Southern gentleman boy
hello Dolores now it says here that you
need to go to the IRS ADAT i arrest pay
right now not fun there's a warrant out
for you they say you're gonna be in a
lot of trouble they're gonna kick your
door down and you know they're police so
they will shoot your dog yeah that's
start that is kind of close to the some
of the stuff I've heard oh the future
sounds great yes I can't wait
can I buy stock in that do will be run
up by Robin Hood add character and you
found another one hands on it around
holy [ __ ] 140 thousand this is big news
is well that's three days ago so his
brother the same Dan can you hook me up
with a Coke Zero
mm-hmm sure damn she's got a lot of
smiles on her face you got a little
Saudi it's like I don't want to hit your
Saudi okay I look oh I got I'll share
with you ah you're really cute if y'all
got take my old Saudi it's Christmas
absolutely and walk away pray that
refreshing Christmas thank you
all right okay Robby let's enjoy this
guy's like that's all I mean this guy's
just like I feel bad for the CEO oh this
guy's amazing how does he know every
Nigeria's on you but like he clicks into
it every time the camera cuts them he's
got great timing really it really does
great awareness you might be right maybe
it is a she so well I'm it's hard it's
hard for me to tell in this video but
the older video from like a few months
ago 100% she because like she gave
interviews in character but this this
person could be a gentleman I'm all for
those listening it's a person he or she
with a top hat had there just as a bit
of ma Polly guy with it and they got a
sack of money with them with $20 bills
popping out at the top very and they
look very intrigued ariel's or a dress
like super professional
yeah the angle just having a laugh is
this a Geico commercial the bag is like
Geico on it right honestly if I thought
of that first and I lived in the area I
would do that yeah they're making some
statement yeah no I mean like truthfully
there being some political statement
about I don't even know what they're
saying one day everyone in the audience
is gonna be like gonna grow like they'll
be two of them
really out of control right I can't
shoot without sure nobody's taking these
into a joke god this guy is getting a
lot of air time he's loving this I know
something about like how our privacy is
up for sale I guess to do one of those
things I'm surprised we don't have this
dudes like Twitter or that's what I'm
saying credit can they not hold up the
sign that's like following me on Twitter
that would be a real it's not as cool
that's just smart marketing yet no
actually I just found they actually did
an AMA on reddit so all your questions
will be answered why all two of them
right hey guys I'm here to take two
questions who are you and why okay thank
you for coming to my AMA pornhub put
together the world's most viewed
categories of porn in 2018 by
geographical location I love it I love
it this says a lot now what fascinates
me the most you'll see there's some
interest the u.s. loves lesbian who
doesn't all south of merica really loves
lesbian Chile however is it one time and
all ah yeah all I think so many people
in Japan are watching gente they [ __ ]
up the whole content yeah Japan I get it
Russia I'm very surprised it's gotta be
like all of the Eastern Bloc actually
it's like all of the former Soviet Union
that blows my mind that I mean I've
tried hentai just out of pure curiosity
it's so weird so when you have real porn
available yeah now I just jerk off to
Captain Planet the second I moved to
Russia
live-action porn but in cartoon girl so
I'm I'm shocked about Russia because
normally when I see these types of
graphs and bar charts and such the the
most repressed places so like if if gay
porn or if gay art is just largely band
and
round upon then usually that territory
has gay porn you know that's like
they're they're like states in the US
it's all about that or anytime the
Republican National Convention comes
exactly so that's why I'm shocked about
Russia since like you know being gay is
a big no-no in Russia they're all about
the hentai but I think if you if you
green you if you took a closer look
because when I've seen that where you're
talking about like in the US like in
Kansas everyone's watching gay porn
gallery but it's so broad what is the
green one the green well so you've got
Arab horn which is in North Africa and
then evany and all in Africa which is
black I find that interesting the people
they're trying they want to get down
with their own [ __ ] and then South s
Southeast Asia you've got Asian can I
just say my favorite is big dick and in
India their favorite look at Spain Spain
stands alone what is it there's a lot of
that's different than stock milk that's
literally it's like pile the cooter
challenges beyond melt like old as [ __ ]
because I was gonna say basically or
technically all porn is mature but if
it's elderly is weird really all those
people I would guess that's like Kyle I
don't know
no a MILF I would say is like thirty to
fifty mature is like sixty plus like
paint like damn I did about it in Spain
apparently not a whole country right
let's analyze that yeah I honestly don't
know if France Francis to the east was
that I think Romania more such [ __ ]
idiot Germany right Germany's into anal
or synchronism to anal what was right
again
no that is less but it's not England
sweet this is this is Germany no that's
Germany but what you pointed to is not
England this oh [ __ ] me here it is
tomorrow's go what is this Norway you -
yes [ __ ]
that's actually sweet nice I guess we're
in Norway
no that's Finland all right well the
same place I got that one right
you know why are you eating a live for
that can I say Europeans make fun of
Americans for being like so stupid you
try to name five states from the United
States I don't live here I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm just label them like normal
yeah give us a break here I'm surprised
that lesbian porn is so predominant yeah
like everywhere across the seas almost
like the normal well we're all friends
here apparently like a Western
civilization thing yeah high value on
lesbians for gay acceptance gays are
icky but lesbians founded that I thought
we lived in lesbian is that lesbian I
thought that was I thought I thought
this was a map with names of the places
the big big country is can you help me
Claire so who's in a big dick
pakistanian who are these guys I think
that's Nepal these have little dicks I
think I think why lesbian porn so
popular because men and women I think
sure it's crowd-pleasing
yeah it's something out of yeah you know
because dudes were like hey that's hot
and then of course girls like girls like
I don't want to see dudes yes yeah
honestly no that's true yeah we learned
earlier than women don't enjoy sex
finally entering that people in Africa
are watching ebony and in North Africa
Arab well I know their era but I just
think kind of you want to see your own
content on peeps you want to relate
police say they are watching more gente
hi oh it's great but okay so I think but
what is the appeal Zach Ertz or Ian or
Dan do any of you guys watch hentai no
I'm like you Ethan like I checked it out
out of curiosity but I don't I don't
find it I don't find it arousing
everyone is saying no in the room Ian
it's gotta be a yes yeah well in is
always the odd one out and I appreciate
his honesty so Ian tell me what you and
Ty are you in that's a negative for me
and I'm offended person never heard of
that anime Jack come on be level with us
now I'm in the moves are you really wait
are you really yeah and so what do you
know why you prefer older women or is
that just a preference you know where
the milfs well you would fit in in India
apparently and we have got that's India
dance many places name with and then
also we've got what do we got here that
would be poor bowling it's like I said
if a country existed at World War two no
I know what it is because involved the
video games have played that's all of my
job if he comes from hearts of iron
now will you came now Dan and in we what
kind of porn category do you guys watch
well I was gonna say you know it's
interesting the whole milf thing it was
sort of an eye-opening thing when I
realized that I'm old enough that milf
porn is just women my age that's kind of
like that was oh [ __ ] moment right there
oh that's real that's sooo real so are
you saying that they're home yeah I
don't agree with that when I look at
milf porn I see like old ladies with
fake titties you said it earlier it kind
of runs a range but it does seem too
milf is almost like late 20s to 40s and
50s let me see this now when you go to a
porn site do you type milf are you know
we can we consciously seeking it out
anal I feel like we're not giving anal
its fair share of the spotlight when
does but the whole countries do it I was
expecting some more anal in the charts I
saw somebody point out that the in the
Mideast there the anal block if you will
the anal block I really what anal block
is the exact territory of the old
Persian Empire for some reason so
there's got to be some correlation
history buffs please hooker stop please
help us out is that Germany well that's
fine because Iceland apparently
oh yeah Iceland is just anals brankovic
is Italy milfs
yes oh yeah I'm not surprised that's
very yeah you know what if so then
there's that and then there's also a lot
a lot of weird stuff like that you can't
do with real people like tentacle wreck
rape and it's just and I it's just so
bizarre but I think a lot of its got to
be hardwired from kids watching because
there's some bomb-ass cartoon characters
like kill the kill
have you seen that anime I know about
walking like that's straight-up hentai
and those girls are [ __ ] slamming
dude well that's it but I never watched
an tomato only dole in my opinion only
as an adult I've seen that [ __ ] but if I
watch that as a kid I would have been
like dick out and all day I would've
been like that would Awards my [ __ ]
money you know and that would have like
rearranged all my sexual desire you know
like at an early if you introduce that
[ __ ] at an early age cuz like a lot of
anime as you said it's hyper sexualized
in one way or another
hey man when we were growing up we had
misty from Pokemon that's it I'll give
you that I'll give you that April and
Mike hurdles but some cartoon characters
the way they try them with like like
like titties everywhere and then the
cameras always from the back you looking
at liquor bag bump stop Ethan it's too
sexy I think their heart is there
and option on there talking not looking
looking for hurry was not furry really
is that a porn category oh yeah I guess
so you're right do you guys have a porn
preference I type in porn and then I
have like everything available and then
depending on my mood my drunkenness
level well I just go yeah that one
what are usually then I go back to
reading The Wall Street Journal you know
go ahead jack I asked the boy not know
um you know there's a whole trope
embarrassed nude female enf that's like
I've seen it on reddit where it's like
yeah yes yes yes there's a subreddit was
it called embarrassed happy and bare is
I don't know the subreddit I don't know
that one but there are but he'd like
that is so you like so it's it's just
like like I help you through this and
yeah thank you no embarrassed new famous
females is exactly what it sounds like
I'm cute it's a whole genre
it's like oops you know it's that kind
of [ __ ] like Oh No yeah like because
there's a young kid you saw the Marilyn
Manson Marilyn Manson got you really
twisted trope right being embarrassed by
old pinups right yeah that's a big part
of it I'm sure you know very retro yeah
yeah so I'm an old school he's old
school
yeah absolutely they are milfs no well
no they're no they're dead they're good
milfs that's a that's a corpse I'd like
to [ __ ] him alright yeah now it's that
like I'd like to kill you baby yes see
ILF yeah whatever the
all right well there you have it oh this
is a fun little little excursion wasn't
it fun rabbit hole to dive into people
like porn
I just kid I've [ __ ] a [ __ ]
jerk-off it's you yeah I don't want any
but it's just what tenacious - you guys
talked about yeah it's like not bad well
we're talking furry stuff yeah oh that's
interesting yeah because I I find the
furry thing strange and wild - cuz
apparently they have a flock for the
dick
we made it I'm doing no I think that's
real oh we did make that up you guys you
guys didn't see all of the the correct
the record emails that I received
that's weak all the fairies are pissed
yeah not even piss but they're like
there's a lot more to it I think I will
have you know reduced to being givers
and they're like it's not it there's
much more than you think
oh I'm so glad you asked you know yeah
that's that's what your thing is
why am I the [ __ ] Authority oh [ __ ]
yeah thing is you know what furries have
sex they say that but you don't don't
worry I got you in the costume yeah what
does that need a name last time I
checked it's called sex yeah I think I
know about you thing before I knew it
like an oaf was like this is in or out
of the costume you things in yes you got
any what's the point
flap out I don't ride or die baby like
because they ain't got a flap on their
roster because they're not like a like a
mouth hole for your day maybe the
yipping is part of the role play you
know yeah for short stories are sexual
like that cuz like a I have a number of
viewers but a number of my my viewers
are in fact furries and you can tell by
news on Twitter and Shashi an avatars -
Ethan based on the email I don't
discriminate ake everyone
I need views desperately these guys
watch the gamer Awards at all like a few
days ago
I think the guy who won gamer of the
year yeah it showed up in a costume it
was he was a furry yeah any cam is very
costume and he accepted it now is being
a furry kind of like how in the 90s
people were like it's okay to be gay
are we taking it that far I think so I
don't think it's that are they looking
for acceptance or the conductance but
why is it well Dan you got emails were
they serious or not they weren't
honestly they weren't really that mad it
was more just like hey I just want to
let you know it's not always a sexual
thing blah blah blah that's so like you
know they were just sort of expanding on
it so yeah then as far as like my
viewers like you know when I get tweets
and stuff from people you can see by
their profile picture that like you know
it's them in a very thing yes and I've
never met a mean one yet so I'm prone to
just like it's cool dammit why you guys
been all nice and I look like cynical
eyes I have a whole list of hateful
things that yeah I always look like the
[ __ ] not their people's today but I I
did ask this question when when
Tenacious D was here if they are they're
really into the role-playing so they
must paint their dick red I'm sorry
who's they Ares okay because we like a
dog boner
like a dog boner like it goes read it
the red rocket kind of thing cuz if you
just pay it take out a human dick that
ain't right I don't think I don't that's
that's a very amusing thought yeah trust
me yes I don't think they take it to
that level now to correct me if I'm
wrong for who yeah but I don't think
they go that like that's that's pretty
that's a method like that's some Daniel
day-lewis [ __ ] right there yeah some
real Marlon Brando [ __ ] like what about
animals with really strange penis right
this leaky ones like hurting chucks well
[ __ ] ducks yeah yeah yeah so they
probably mutilate their penis use need a
little spirit gum in a big you know prop
we need a three plenty of shops won't
that be amazing you know what's the
furries in LA
there you go are
emailed and broadcasted a sugar
production calm let's get a furry here
in costume I've got a hundred and one
questions clear you can do half in and
half out do it I want I want one who's
also acquainted with the sexual aspect
because I didn't want to I want that I
want to know if they paint their dick
red you should have one non sexual hurry
does it for the cosplay and then one who
like dude you need help that's the
future of this podcast you look at Joe
Rogan oh oh let me get a scientist on
about sleeveless no bird what the [ __ ]
are you hey you're welcome by the way is
it just catching up to the furry train
well I know I'm not caught up but I just
I never thought of actually getting one
in here
I've already had a like a narc use my
life on the internet where like when I
first learned about furries I was like
that's weird I hate it right and then it
evolved into like oh there's nothing
wrong with these [ __ ] people at all
right have you done any common etiquette
video on furries I don't think so people
have given them such a hard time on the
Internet that's like I feel like it'd be
target I don't want to be lumped in with
the the manor side I think honestly no
in my experience they have a very good
sense of humor about it if you did it
tastefully what do you do do stuff
tastefully comedic wise right I think no
no you do you I think I think you get
away with it honestly it would be very
funny and then like yeah if I did well
I'm just perplexed
I just am further no like now I mean and
their costumes are so weird like like
the for your face it's just it's strange
what's weird about it Ethan well they
all look like a [ __ ] acid trip like
humanoid fought like it's just weird I
don't know let's get a let's move on
we're like an hour like I was in a furry
if there's like an outside group called
the scalese million yeah they're all
reptilians you don't need that
conspiracy theory who says I have to
have fur but then do they put the scales
aluminous no just be like all covered in
turtle shell I like it yeah they do
they have a creepy face do you guys
that's what I'm saying there's a creepy
face the dude who's recording this video
calls him
little homie so he's a little homie I
think that's how they preferred to be
real Oh like like we man kind of thing
he just says little homie he doesn't
know him well okay one thing at a time
so we're looking at furries the faces
creeps me out and I'm sorry if that
offends you the word divides into the
group of people that is creeped out
lady's face oh I didn't mean to click
well there you have it anyway right
but look at that all hotel guests should
behave like these furries furries are
live in achill politeness
are you a furry look at your chest man
you've got a furry you're and that's
your care I mean I'm sure I'm defending
them a lot I guess it makes you wonder
it makes you wonder no no I I personally
am NOT but like it's just oh but do you
guys find their face creepy I find the
face cream now if I'm being honest I
mean it's I say this I don't get it I
don't get the appeal I do not I don't
find them creepy mm-hmm Wow
I don't find them creepy and I like I
don't want to like I don't want to make
fun of them because I feel I feel I
don't want to make fun like a whole
community and it's just like no no I got
none right I get likewise yeah what's
there to get mad at beautifully put
beautifully put
I'm pissed and dance in my eyeline right
now they didn't see the first or
anything well well they were
anthropomorphic we're trouble I mean
like what what else you need to know
foxes and dogs and whatnot like you've
seen furries you know what it looks like
you go
you know what if that was like the only
way I could get off I mean I guess it's
not a sex thing but if that was the only
way I could get off do I would I would
be the best fairy in the world I would
have the dopest [ __ ]
I would like what's your first ona
[ __ ] rabbit great Maddock implants put
into my into my legs yeah so I could hop
like one oh I love it okay so yeah then
like like hydraulics ins yeah if I
wasn't like in the action around me I'll
just bleep out of that great great ice
breaker and also great conversation
ender and it's however another night
just leap into the ceiling I don't have
to watch Netflix go to bed to our sauce
and and turn in knock yourself out quick
old concussion and mmm ready to you so
what are you guys watching lately you
watching anything good you split that
that clip up into multiple yeah so tired
hearing that do you watch red letter
media yes mmm their latest video is a
god what was it about what they do as if
if you know them you know they do a
series called best of the worst when
they just reviewed terrible forgotten
VHS films of the 80s and 90s mmm
so I'll spoil the surprise because it
happened so quickly everything is going
fine you know they do like the little
fling keto or Plinko thing of like
selecting the movies they drop a ball
and a whole grid like lands on a VHS
tape sometimes it lands on players
choice which means that they can choose
whatever video they want so Atlanta and
players choice out walks in [ __ ]
Macaulay Culkin and he holds up a copy
of home alone for and he's like we're
watching this guy Wow and they so they
actually watch home alone for women
totally cold and they're all being
making jokes at everyone's excited so
or and it's so damn funny and it's so
like wholesome cousins like oh how cool
is that I got the polkan they got they
got Kevin McCallister I think that's his
name right like this he live Balkan no I
mean no he's Macaulay Culkin but the in
home alone oh he's Kevin right he's
Kevin I'm wearing more I think like
raynella yeah yes yeah and I think I
think he's a big fan of red letter media
and red letter media strangely like okay
what they're like yeah I think
everyone's see really a big fan yeah I
don't know why secretly well because
their channels relah
I mean it's not small but relatively
smaller than well-known they are and
they're also like genius and yeah I have
like their own word they have their own
a pretty they have less than 900,000
subscribe you're gonna get to know why
like if someone pushes for them because
they deserve 10 maybe some dick jokes
next to my bed had more subscribers than
them and I was like this just like this
is a government plot to be fair I love
your dick jokes but like that I love LED
red letter media even more I know they
should have better media yeah it's just
because they're not like the way I view
them they're not even a YouTube channel
I feel like they ascended beyond a
YouTube channel cuz they don't do the
whole like hey what's up everybody
what's going on and today like they just
go in they're like well Mike well the
very question they're very awesome but
so funny so so dry funny where the [ __ ]
did they get their warehouse is what I
want to know red letter media where did
you get this goddamn warehouse and I'll
move there early they destroy all the
time what I wonder is if are are they
furs oh you know they are rich Evans
might be like hey Josh i believe i
[ __ ] love this video I assume that
this little homeys on some kind of drug
mm-hmm cuz he seems high I'm light on
enter he seems high energy okay but I'll
let you guys enjoy is he high on good
vibes good vibes only Oh
yeah he's not associate associated with
the guy who hooked a watermark by the
way I will say he's fret he's dressed
freshest he'll for having to shop like
kids [ __ ] like that's a pretty fresh
outfit he's got it at Jordans on Jordan
be nice what up he knows what's up yeah
he looks good but not as he's not having
a good day
I got no audio oh it's okay I can I can
read lips he's saying Murray's forever
furries together trying to rob this
convenience store later than weaponry oh
that's not gonna work I need a weapon
he's throwing gummy treats at the
cashier similar he's trying to steal
he's saying fill that bag up I don't
even see the bag no here he gave it to
oh my god oh that's that's a bad move
fill that bag up honest yeah well at one
point you'll hear they offer him fifty
two the whole day
everyone just gathered around a lot
enjoyed a little homies throwing gummy
treats go that bad this is the most
gangster [ __ ] I ever seen this is the
alternate ending to a training day
actually I was gonna say this is an
alternate Kingdom Hearts 3 and coming in
January I would love to have for him to
be a playable character and everything
ok
fill that bag up holding his weapon is
gummy is gummy boy Holy's coming come on
dude easy gig
very angry so what'd you do today class
there's a great ending - oh yeah I love
how the police are just like that'd be
like if shawshank redemption' had a bad
ending I think ultimately this is a
tragic video because this is a guy he's
a soul of a gangster and the body of a
child well and even those recording him
who are trying to root him on to help
him can't help but laugh as he's gently
laid down by the police is a little slap
sticky it literally is like some
physical comedy slapstick was I think
use on something yeah Chuck half a beer
and then he must obliterated on the
ground
that was amazing that's got a nice
finishing like if I worked for the
Mortal Kombat game I'd be getting in
touch with this guy's people throwing
wine bottle on baby bears Smash Brothers
ultimate has DLC coming out yeah just
some food play yeah right that way thank
you by the way that games freaking
awesome
oh you guys yeah I don't all I want to
be doing
disgusting sexist brain didn't label you
know I I don't play any games but I like
this one it's fun
which job do I don't okay get yourself a
switch by plead blast never played Smash
Brothers was in couch yeah me too cube I
was I walk into a room and it was like
the liveliest thing I've ever seen I was
like god I wish I was good at this it's
fine well I used to be real good but now
I suck at menial on the same level which
is fun but the single-player is like
amazing it's usually takes like Zoe for
I wanna beat the single-player they have
English plates yeah but it's got really
fun interesting upgrades and spirits and
all the levels have different
difficulties and different special
conditions and its really surprising
it's really fun and you have to play it
to unlock fighters and I was like what
Dan who's your with your main we've been
playing a lot of Falcon hell yeah
but just just what's available to me
okay Kirby yeah Kirby's what's up
currently that'd be all day Kirby really
knows how to fill that that's great but
guy so I'm just kind of in like I am
overwhelmed because I grew up on the n64
version of smash where when you unlock
everything there are 12 [ __ ]
character I know I know
and in this new game there's over 70 and
the amounts whoa and the amount of level
looking levels there were nine there's
no it's offering it's like I'm a nerd
like I grew up on the end like even more
I never had a Gamecube so I never played
melee tank he was awesome I went right
from n64 to wheat yeah so I never had
that in-between I know the game key was
a great system but like I grew up on the
on the laggy slow and 64 version like if
there are too many characters and smash
and n64 it would slow it down it was
like a PowerPoint presentation and 15
frames a second and now we're at the
switch you play in handheld mode it's
I've never played this game so this is
my first it's over last weekend and we
just like played on like character
now have you played online yet because I
haven't tried I only just bought you
know it's funny because I now you have
to buy online like the yeah which I hate
so I just did that the other day to play
one of my buds I haven't tried it yet go
but the online it has a good offer
because you get to play all the retro
games you get to stream on like what are
some what are some examples of retro
game like Mario 3 you get to call a good
well gets really like original good
Galica you get to play there's like a
lot of really retro freaking cool ass
games dope that's a huge part I think
there keep adding all the classic [ __ ]
there that's what they need to do they
need to build up like the Virtual
Console that's what the Wii and the Wii
U had going for it they need like more
classic 8-bit 16-bit games yeah and I
think they're doing that yeah so it's
really cool
not smart fill that back up new games we
got a new story story armored trucks
pills cash on wowsie highway drivers
pull over on the freeway rush to grab
dollar bills someone fill a bag up so uh
a Brinks truck I guess the back just
sprung open and like 20 hate when that
are just all over the freeway it's quite
something
now what would cause that to happen
like was it triggered to open up the
spring open or it was just a mechanical
I think it was in an accident actually
now this guy by the way this poor son of
a gun on the freeway picking up dollar
bills
that's the Brinks guy trying to save his
job when people realize those are dollar
bills flying around and not garbage it's
pulling over to pick them up for the for
the work of the poor like anyone that
has to collect that just establish their
[ __ ] right that's the Brinks guy
thing well he's having a good time
Ami's yeah yeah and it brings uniform as
seen here trying to collect the money
I'm sure you think the whole thing is
hilarious I mean what the [ __ ] else am I
gonna do
that's scary I mean like you can't just
hop out of here you can't pull over and
just hop out here yeah
Frogger it you know think of this guy
he's like oh there's my fearless no way
Yeah right this was the perfect
situation for our little homie though he
would have filled a lot yeah
sit him out like a Roomba crap oh wait
no no that's accurate no it you're right
no I hold fine yeah I think that's fine
can we get an answer is that fine we
don't know judges let's not
now to be fair my drinks I don't think
you're gonna pick up enough dollar bills
to pay for that
no this is New Jersey so all those
accidents were gonna happen anyway it's
whether that Turnpike gets him and the
the NJ Turnpike I've driven it many
times it there's a lot of dollars baby
their 20s all of them that's that's
their twenties so it's like I don't know
listen if I'm working like minimum wage
I'm pulling over and grabbing those
ponies dude I could be Mark Wahlberg I'd
pull over and grab 528 John it's after
7:30 that's true
so I'm Mark Wahlberg I'm pulling over
I'm punching the Chinese man face I'm
blinded him gonna provide a cryo chamber
Ethan I received a message that he may
not have blinded the man he the mine the
man was already blind he punched me
behind me no what a [ __ ] yes I heard
he blinded him in one I suspect he was
missing an eye he was thinking I you
know can we pour out can you look it up
on Wikipedia because I want to get we
asked Mark Wahlberg I want to know
everybody oh no no no don't do that I
don't want to start trouble
I mean instant family was a great movie
I said I love it acting
mark I love your acting your cool guy I
love that whole shtick I want some kids
I think I'm really into this you know I
just have three kids that's it he seemed
like a happy guy so you know he'll see
that part and we fall asleep because
it's like the whole podcast no I have a
feeling he's gonna like show up like
he's like smoking from his cryo
treatment he's like piece of dry ice hey
I heard you talking [ __ ] that's not cool
man I've been working up for three hours
today I'm interrupting my family time
for this okay right right
drag my kids along now they're gonna
beat you up now I'm gonna throw down
okay and I don't want to do this I don't
want to do this I'm a sweet guy you know
but you forced me to do this look I
changed I can't open if that Chinese man
had a week I don't blind people anymore
a great idea for a podcast is just three
guys doing Mark Wahlberg in front
listen that's all welcome to the
Wahlberg welcome to the Wahlberg podcast
okay talk about the Civil War don't know
how it started though with a lot be nice
the button be nice to black people is it
that hard I mean hey I'll be treat
everyone with respect am i right guys
all right that was the podcast thanks
for turning it mm-hmm I mean black
people are people okay I mean what's so
hard to understand about that Lincoln
died for it I mean that Lincoln's I like
that that's probably what they're gonna
update on the mark the Wahlberg's we get
him to sign a release
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to find a
good source on it and the story is kind
of weird it definitely gets arrested
Martin an impression of Mark Wahlberg
yeah I can't new kids on the block
reunion but my uh I keep on my Calvin's
to stop the aid from getting in you know
the story for a long time was that he
blinded him however I see an article
where they interviewed the guy that got
beaten up and he claims he was already
blind in one eye and so that was kind of
a Miss but the source on this is the
Daily Mail which was garbage so yeah
listen I can play that guy he was
already blind hey can I just quickly
shout out my wife Erin because she shits
on the Daily Mail every day on our
Instagram and it's hilarious like she
screencap stories and then just right in
her like own captions like um it's
incredible well like if you want to shed
on the do we not find more legitimate
information because I'm very okay well
already blind story cuz I thought yeah I
was trying to punch it back in okay
wouldn't go in the first time run out of
power
very important update on the furry penis
question yeah God and somebody has even
hide an watching podcast right now
furries don't paint their pins but but
obviously there is a website called bad
dragon that has quote wearables which
are toys you can put on your pain into
making it look like an animal's get my
shape of water dish I guess my question
is how prevalent are these toys in the
furry community
he does not he's not clarified but
enough to support a a vibrant economy
now what now again so you're talking
about having a sex act where your penis
doesn't even because you
it's a wearable strap-on I mean people
do that well if you have a dick do you
strap-on if you wanted to look like a
duck's corkscrew [ __ ] yeah interesting
so does your dick I'm sweared so does it
go over your erect penis or are you
flossing Dan circuitry to one to one
match your P we don't even have that VR
yet that's true that's I'll be the next
one psvr to I got a question for you
guys is [ __ ] a sex robot cheating
[ __ ] that's that's a tough one
that's a tough one you know that sounds
like that kind of thing we're while I'm
[ __ ] a sex road I'd be like this
ain't cheating no I'm gonna say no I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say no I'll be bald
and just take a stance and say no
because it's a [ __ ] robot
I don't think okay it's at what point
when you have like super advanced like
let's say it's got like a personality
and if [ __ ] sucks and swirls on your
dick like right no human can I
absolutely stand you're like you know
what I'm gonna go take off baby
I'll be back I'm just gonna go hang out
and I'll be back you go you [ __ ] you
have the best you [ __ ] your robot I
don't think it's cheating because it's a
rope I will say I'm like I'm gonna go
I'm gonna be bald because so you do you
think it's yeah what are you upset if
she knew that you were decking out to
[ __ ] not a joke I can I got your
battery on masturbation that's all it is
it's very I just think it depends on the
kind of robot like if it's in West
Warren where they're all that's the
making is so you think [ __ ] a West
world robot isn't cheating
no I don't think so you know it's funny
Aaron and I have talked about this she's
like hello you absolutely go to town on
some hot robot I think now I'm not
kidding we talked until that robot says
so what are we you start like
complaining about robots like well you
know you're gonna get rid are you
happier with me you know I don't think
it's I don't want Eli Gough getting some
like [ __ ] insane robot [ __ ] like 10
inch [ __ ] robot insane [ __ ] no act
this [ __ ] handsome that's fine but
what if you go and hang out with the
robot start spending time yeah spending
time okay that's when it gets a little
weird but when you're like when when
you're not [ __ ] the robot you mean
and just like yeah plane smashed opening
a door all right get out it's like the
printer in your bedroom that you have to
keep them plugged you know you're like a
westward season one before they found
out I'm gonna spoil it so if you ever
watch West world just skip for the next
30 seconds yeah yeah yeah so when
they're in there they're scanning their
brain to like clone them or they're
making like personality types okay
well they're all [ __ ] robots they can
just collect their semen and clone them
there's like a huge seam bank that's all
Westeros a huge semen bank I think you
call the humans just get a bunch of
semen but you're not gonna like I don't
know what you do with this you just get
nice even though get a bunch of semen do
that well that would be really funny
questworld big wish was like hey you hey
thirty kids
we've been there are real people and
they're your kids because we have so
much semen we don't want to do that all
we just have buckets see man just save
it all we save all of it there's like a
volt you know they like the vault with
everyone's brain it's backed up it's
just what if it's just this big a
swimming pool of semen this is uh all of
our guests what is about to come we're
gonna see what that does what and you're
giving the writers too many ideas you
guys you gotta lock it up okay you guys
can come back spoilers over just a bunch
of semen I'm not spoiled well I gave
away the plot a little bit oh yeah not
really got to convoluted like to me like
I saw season one that's fun and then
like I hurt I didn't even start season
two I just heard all these rumors and I
liked it
really I just heard too many people
going like what the [ __ ] I love not well
it's not like I got anything better to
watch but I can't watch I don't watch
Game of Thrones yeah okay I like getting
extremely high and watching like a
handful of shows in West world's one of
them because I kind of don't give a [ __ ]
what happens I'm not gonna get mad
whatever they do I'm just gonna be like
all right that's where you going how do
you normally get mad while I'm into this
[ __ ] ride I think I would get a panic
attack trying to watch it high cuz it's
already so hard to follow like what's
going on I get panic attacks high any
time so yeah I don't the watch I've
never watched episodes of a TV show so
many times just to understand what
happened it's so complicated I don't
that's what turns me off it's like that
guy Wow I accuse 250 bucks right yeah
way that wash is like I assume that you
understand what you're supposed to do
and whatnot because no you're done can't
try too hard
am i that guy you're dying here
you know it's like everything you're
like that we Game of Thrones - is my you
250 well I read the book which is
required I love Game of Thrones but I'll
be damned if there are like some
characters whose names I forget and when
they pop up sometimes it's like this big
revelation of character pops up and I go
ah [ __ ] who's that again like it's
supposed to be this big dramatic mole
what's sure i keel like 300 something
like an [ __ ] that guy in your
punching bag you gotta be that guy
someone's gonna be probably that guy
yeah we're gonna do say nice things
about what's wrong
I like Westworld complain about like
Incept ones complaining about like
Inception like I had to watch it 20
times don't think about anyone's
complained about at the time that was
different I'm with you on that one
because like people complain about that
ending and it being ambiguous it's like
well I mean that was the point it's fine
movies but they're like layers in and
they're in the mob handle it it takes
like two tries and you get it's like
yeah there's going into more dreams yeah
yeah but it's entertaining more times
well to be frank we do all have at least
250 IQ my IQ is just the letters I and Q
which I'm afraid to take an IQ test I
think I can't face the reality that I
probably have like a 90 I don't think I
think I have I don't think because I'm
not the book grandparent um you're not a
90 son you're a 101 you're a 101 to me
even no don't matter what the doctors
tell you barely over the mediocre
threshold I feel like I'm really bad at
like pattern recognition which is like a
lot of what the IQ is really you know
like when we did that escape room and me
and either were set with the task of
doing some logic puzzle and I'm and I'm
like I'm the DA we couldn't figure it
out well escape rooms are different
because they
they they put you in a time constraint
and I feel like that girl folks like you
that wears longer pretty man you're like
social like were you with strangers
ya know would mostly fingers yeah I mean
like friends or friends so we didn't
know everyone I got it I learned a lot
about myself in the escape room in that
like I'm kind of a [ __ ]
like in a [ __ ] way not like a [ __ ]
yeah yeah okay so I had the puzzle
figured out like I was on my way tell
anyone I didn't believe in myself that I
had it like okay so I give like a broad
stroke here like there are a bunch of
books sensitive geniu the way that you
set the books up is is the trick because
there was like you use the flashlight
and it's a black light and you run it
along the books and it tells you the
combination for the safe so I'm over
here playing with these [ __ ] books
like oh maybe they should be like this
maybe they should be like this and I was
starting to get there and then someone
else someone came over this the-the-the
like alpha male of the group who I know
it was me were you wearing your soy boys
[Laughter]
and then I was just playing with them
and I was a you give it a try man just
completely gave you had it figured out I
had I was probably three minutes away
from figuring out and I only know that
because this other guy came over [ __ ]
them all up didn't know what he was
doing and walked away and then the there
was a an actor in the room so there was
someone who was like she added the bed
oh really was like a zombie or something
like now I and she was like you know you
like the rules were don't get near this
person yeah don't touch them which means
that someone's touched them before it's
a rule because someone did it yeah and
she just like I could see her break
character and get exasperated and she
walked over redid everything I did and
set it up yelled at it like not it with
words just went and then like left the
wife and saw the egg so what she solved
it she solved it but she did what I did
after you solve commuted his way right
because you didn't have the the audacity
the courage all I heard was they're
calling me a [ __ ] that's right no
that's gotta [ __ ] with you man that's
gotta fight a part with me a little big
show
I was right about that all right but you
didn't have the confidence yeah for the
rest of it I try to take the initiative
and I was wrong to have really owe you
overtime we did I hear I was like yeah
I'm a [ __ ] genius at this I got that
250 just that one aspect that you are
the one thing I don't like the escape
room I don't like the social situation I
don't like the social pressure I am NOT
alpha I am NOT outgoing and I'm not
smart so all those combined not a good
time those combined trapped in a little
room yeah I think you need to be with
the right peeps like a flashback to
middle school it's like doing I hear
that I hear you I was not good at those
tests jack Mikey though they used to
give us logic tests and middle school
and all these [ __ ] nerds would like
they like if Beth had 12 cherries and
George punched her in the [ __ ] and she
dropped to whatever was exactly what
their cherries obviously well-regarded
but I was not good at these and there
was like the really dumb people they I
beat them but like I was in a feed but I
was not head of the pack I honestly
think if you're with like a group of
people that you know and like you like
you're cool with they're not friends of
friends of friends they're not like
friends three times removed these are
your homies yeah you're gonna have a
good [ __ ] time maybe it's like I'm
gonna say I suck at room escapes I've
done a number of them have you yeah but
I have a good time cuz I'm with like
people I trust and I know and I like
yeah and it makes the whole yeah have
you ever been like with your friends in
an escape room because you don't allow
have you ever looked at when your
friends and said yourself damnit guys
[ __ ] yes I have definitely once you
don't just say HUBO was a situation now
things that I'll give you his Twitter
handle and everything no no no it was
just it was just like Eric there's me it
was um no it was like I don't know the
exact example it was just like pieces
drawn together I was wondering what the
hell is going on you're
no it's just like the guy was clearly
clueless or girl
let's not discriminate could have been
anyone could have been a anyone hey Dave
yeah was a guy but like he or she was
just like so clueless about like just
everything they didn't really get it but
like it did I didn't think less of the
person because I already knew that going
in I was like already knows I know
you're dead weight them I'm a dead
weight is so it was just kind of like it
was it was fun like we just had a good
so I felt like dead weight I did not
okay anything okay that's fair but there
there were so many people that it was
kind of a fun my my wife did all the
carrying Aaron did all the carrying and
all the caring and the caring carrying
and caring but like she and you know I
was like a 1 I kind of fell like dead
weight too but on the other hand I was a
little proud but I still had fun cuz I
was like just with my guys just going
like I think those goes here I'll [ __ ]
no I don't know I think you have to be
in the right frame of mind
but I mean also you know if you don't
like escape rooms you don't like escape
room we should do an escape room
together with friends that you trust
like like not less friends of friends no
I would are you kidding and I suck at
escape rooms I'm not gonna be the guys
do it
Oh God come down now set up some [ __ ]
cameras and we're gonna get nothing done
well my broadcast to the world cuz I
look like a [ __ ] just do it oh yeah
me I said he wanted Eric I want to
broadcast it reaming mindset for one
[ __ ] I'm the charity [ __ ] Yeah right
Eric's happy Forex are sick kids great
what's the name of the charity Eric's
sick kids yeah did you make them sick
are they yeah we're I don't have to
answer that
yeah kids I love that they're my kids
and they're sick alright we need help
what else he needs that no yeah you're
really sick dude mind your business
what's wrong with them I don't have to
answer that can I get in ten bucks
please we have watched on the show
before a compilation of celebrities
performers falling off stage during
their performance and we had an
legendary submission from one of our
fans Matthew slaughter that's a hell of
a last name social actor Matthew slack
so wait Matthew's a celebrity no no this
is submitted it I'm just celebrity is
gamma Collins who I'm not familiar with
she's a UK something going on in the UK
but we took a [ __ ] tumble of a
lifetime me me rot row the UK yeah I
don't think she's like it's like a
podcast yeah so here's Gamma Collins
taking a tumble of a lifetime
[Applause]
oh wow now this gets real fight they
can't lift her up because she's a bit on
that heavier dragon the whole game it's
all game but here it was really funny as
this stage the guy who controls the
stage is like trying to help her out and
he lifts the [ __ ] stage up because
they can't get her up watch this
hydraulic thing I see I see I see
she took it she fell into the hole yeah
she sees I'm good something humor about
she's like laughing no she was a
sweetheart yeah yeah aw it's gotta be
embarrassing I feel a little bad for her
that's got a she actually does an
instant story here and she's got a lot
of charm and charisma about it those
halls and who's putting holes in stages
we saw a lot of people fall victim to
the never sound real she sounds like
she's doing a bit she's a champion man
she took a tumble and she took it a hard
man that's what what more can you want
good for her Oh a felony old doughnut
Ole Miss stage no I mean orphan oh
here's another great one speaking of it
there's another this video had me dying
this mom ooh it's one of my funniest
things I've seen in a long time please
don't don't even tell us anything yeah
just play it okay oh well that's a novel
Jack what why don't just play videos and
not say anything my brother come on okay
a word
[Applause]
okay so this is formula driving yeah
that's right sir instructor it seems fun
oh no no this is how they do it in rally
reasons because it's so intense that
it's a team there's two people one
person drives and one person memorizes
the course and tells them how hard the
turns that's yeah it's all way it's a
two-man sport yeah just imagine so do
you want me to keep talking Jack no no
if Google Maps may occulta was just a
human being in your passenger seat
they're like 0.3 why am i doing his
accent as the first time ever heard me
I'm not gonna do that Tommy I need you
to listen to me for the love of God what
are you doing it's fine Wow for the love
of God semi he can get so intense
please Sammy I'm begging you you have to
listen to me by the way you owe $2,000
to the iron Sammy listen the IRS are
going to arrest you Sammy you move
grandma must pay me ten thousand okay I
thought that it's from like Africa
usually those scams there's always the
nigerian prince
yeah that one doesn't hold water anymore
listen to me Sammy
this way those are the new thing yeah I
think that's the new heart they need
that Southern gentleman convert listen
to me grandma I will [ __ ] you
I've seen those on YouTube they get
really seen though at the end like [ __ ]
it
where's that logo that's exactly it
they boga yeah that sounds familiar uh
oh yeah he had a folder with like porn
the guy like Titan but it was like naked
mole-rats so like it went into him live
once and watched him do it for like a
half-hour [ __ ] and like I'm just eating
lunch watching this and I'm like this is
better
I know better than sex I said it out
loud were you masturbating it I've been
the furry on my bed turned and said what
ha ha better than my bulb is it bad
dragon Dan yeah I think that was a
that's a my fern at my vocabulary that
bad dragon all right so listen to me
Sammy for the love of God so usually
they're mute Manik usually they work
very harmoniously in their team and it's
very intense so he's like a left turn
sharp 45 degrees yeah so that's how they
work so this is good so this is like
fascinating can you imagine if Siri was
like go go go now you missed it you
[ __ ] [ __ ] no I don't work well under
pressure so I write the Lincoln to the
guy I mean honestly he just has to
follow the [ __ ] Road
[Applause]
oh don't tell me
but that's literally god yeah literally
job has to be a backseat driver right
he's [ __ ] you who are breaking the
car don't tell me how to drive that is
terrified I mean like I'm a bad enough
driver as it is but having a guy like
aggressively screaming yeah I just saw a
thumbnail down there it's a good
thumbnail thank you for updating our
position Carl Sagan salvia Yeah right
that's what I noticed too your
turtleneck yep absolutely
that was an so congratulate thanks
seeing me in front of you actually have
a song for I like that
that house beautiful yes yeah hot dad
shut up to the minute dad
I just got a cassette in the mail from
hot dad shut up okay because that yeah
he's he's selling a tape cassette that's
why it's called dumb now that's what I
call hot dad's music [ __ ] genius
he's a genius and how was it did you
find anything to play it on no I've
still got it in the plastic wrap but in
my car I still have a tape deck oh
really so he's going in there
where is he based again like oh I don't
um I don't know if you disclose that I
mean like yeah yeah
don't worry about me not privy yeah yeah
that's fine because like I I asked
because we got to get him over so we can
do karaoke and sing
I'm in a well I cannot see that as an
issue you know what I mean
so that like no well that's all it's not
it's not no well great there's a
Christmas song Raycom in a while we're
talking about the classic songwriter ex
and the skeleton bang fell in a we'll
just it's a hole I apologize I'm just
trying distracting you guys from the
podcast no you're not quick video I'll
get you know I very much I I think it is
here it is so there's this I'm sorry
so here's a couple of Christian growls
girl-girl defined now this now a lot of
Christians they wait until marriage to
have to have coitus but as we all should
as we all should as we talked earlier
abstinence is the only way to prevent
aids counter to what Mark Wahlberg would
have you believe right it's not just the
Calvin's mark sorry but in the pursuit
of Jesus's love they not only waited to
have sex they waited until marriage to
kiss yeah that sounds right each other
[Music]
[Laughter]
so do they go from not even kissing them
to sticking it in okay so I'm reading
the waiting until marriage to kiss isn't
something you'll hear much about from
pop culture although saving sex kissing
or any other intimate act for marriage
is a rarity it can be done so that's
what there
claiming to have done yes interesting I
can't wait to see these nutsack so here
we go
[Music]
loving that like this like ratio very
solid very very song yeah YouTube rewind
[ __ ] right there well let is there any
way we can get them to kiss because with
lesbian is the most popular category and
I do it like most of the world
apparently Russia wait 20 years and
they'll get a kickin in Spain eight
years she's gonna get some day what's
what God's she I'll be doing all sorts
of kissing and and I've never heard that
term used on ironically like she means
it she like she's excited about like
being so quote-unquote loose in that in
that way it's fascinating loose in her
definition like like she's saying I'm
not ashamed to admit it cuz like just
finally you know yes exactly
cuz the guy I like kiss interesting girl
you should have been kissing from the
get-go because like we saw the video no
no what we've seen that video there's
another viral video of like a couple
kissing at their um like the French kiss
at their wedding for the very first time
oh yeah you know that's why before you
get married and it's real cream well
they're taking it to like the buy like
they're like listen just don't [ __ ] I
mean yes but like God [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah well it's true I'm gonna be God
raped the food it's all me and Jack how
are you guys still function I don't know
I really [ __ ] hard it's it's all guys
feel good we felt it in however we go I
don't mean a speak for E but we felt in
an hour over you know what the problem
is I'm pregnant at least you're being
honest make ru sweeps week the one thing
I'm excited for you to be pregnant for
besides that we eat pizza every night
but [ __ ] my happy place no yeah is
that when she's about you're four months
pregnant in about four more months I
think we'll be able to do beach photos
yeah there you go
in white nudes or what pregnancy is all
about are you crazy
but your Christmas cards could be
dynamite yeah when you do exactly that
you just show your you just show your
route so that it looks like an hourglass
it'll be amazing beautiful it's really
can I'm very excited in fact we have an
ultrasound on Monday where we find the
gender for sure even though we think
it's a boy wait so you want it you want
to huh yeah we do has there been like a
thing where you guys know like like oh I
can tell no just in the last ultrasound
they said it looks like it might be a
boy but I wasn't sure are you
tell the world or keep it to yourselves
when you find out we already we're tying
everything yeah yeah are you gonna have
a really cool
gender announcement where you set
California on fire I saw that oh [ __ ] I
slow to pick sorry rich it was a reach
on I do have a sketch plan that I've
already said on this so I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna go you know people put it in
like confetti and they shoot like blue
or yapple yeah so I'm gonna shoot it and
it's gonna be white and I'm gonna look
in the screen and say you [ __ ]
assumed my baby's gender
[ __ ] white you stick get real posed
to the microphone like how is so funny
to me like in Israel we don't have the
baby gender they don't have time they
just shoot them out in the leg that
works let's give you a quick run the
miracle of birth
I think I'm proud forty eight months no
sex that works huh you know if you had
like weird like food stuff something
I've always heard about I am eating
pizza now or dude really so weird
oh my god here's a crazy [ __ ] but she
taught of pickles which is weird okay
that's a break yeah it's pickles and
peanut butter oh yeah like I Love Lucy
style yeah
you know the one thing that's been
happening to me I can go into Ross like
I can't stand the smell like a really
intense fried chicken smell but you were
like okay beforehand mm-hmm interesting
okay so it's something heightened like
your your your sensitivities maybe okay
mm-hmm she doesn't know and she's never
been nauseous so I was cooking chicken
the other day and she had a panic attack
Oh chickens chickens a trigger yeah
that's okay spooks you so you gotta live
that vegetarian life for a little bit
yeah apparently that's fine you're in LA
there are worse places to be vegan or
vegetarian you can get you got a [ __ ]
burger with everything vegetarian style
well tell me or Mexico I may have told
the story but it just is so funny we
literally were dying laughing right a
pizza place in Mexico
and we order on the menu there's a pizza
with like you know bell peppers black
olives mushrooms and pepperoni and we so
we've so we say we want this one but no
pepperoni and he's like oh so do you
want bacon and we're like no meat he's
like oh so do you want steak and we're
like no meat no that else do you want
pork we're like no meat like couldn't
that he was never hauling us we started
looking each other and just laughing
because it was getting so crazy he
couldn't understand he thought he was
misunderstanding that's fascinating yeah
what else is different would food like
do you guys cook a lot at home or like
order out I like it when we cook but
sometimes we got too busy she's eating a
lot that's what's up yeah and I've
gained weight there's no question I
think I've gained like 10 [ __ ] pounds
if I'm being honest since you've been
pregnant and I'm having like the
craziest shits like so much [ __ ] like
well it's crazy I'm sorry my shits have
been insane and here's something they
don't tell you about antidepressants
that I learned ever since I started
taking those my shits have been a 1 one
time is like know like I know it's gross
but you got to come in you get a look at
what would be right to call you in it
was fine because I always had like
diarrhea really loose nasty bowel
movements lots of cleaning issues and so
my shits are like beautifully sculpted
one by one
yeah like the quality like and then I'll
be taking like the fattest shipment the
size of my like intact one piece intact
like guys in my whole forearm like I
haven't been having shits like this
since I was like 12
what's the secret are you like how are
you eating differently are you not a
monster it's the anti too
Preston I guess it oh I'm sorry that's
not on the Metamucil anymore and I do
take the Metamucil but before I started
the antidepressant my shits weren't that
much better like at least the form but
then I guess I guess the antidepressant
makes you constipated and it even me out
oh that's interesting
knightly and [ __ ] like a car you had
like an emergency brake sort of thing
going on where like beyond what a what
like a someone else in in a similar
situation would mean maybe this may be
just the negative effect was a positive
that's right
and sometimes I wonder if I'm sometimes
I wonder if the antidepressant works at
all or if I'm just happy all the time
cuz my shits are so up to chance dude I
guess yeah I get excited every day when
I hit it they're just fiber pills I
swear to god yeah they're just straight
fiber I get excited and every day every
day
and I swear got us the hell out of my
day it's like cuz I've been living my
life with this nightmare of [ __ ] of
shits and now it's just like mmm I come
out dancing wouldn't celebrate that
that's beautiful
do you guys have a nice quality album
you know it's very it's all flow and no
AB okay I got my hills and my valleys
I'm just Gabby [ __ ] now water for eight
years actually dehydrate oh yeah if we
were alive 100 years ago you have died
of dysentery or live dysentery did I'm
pretty sure I would have died on the
Oregon Trail no offense I would have
never left I mean like we all play the
[ __ ] game it was it was even died of
dysentery terrifying yeah
yeah that alone shocked me to my core
about moving anywhere right like what's
the incentive to move anywhere after
playing that game saying I don't want to
go anywhere remember when games were on
[ __ ] floppy disks get me you know
like a hunt like one point four four
megabytes could call it a whole game you
guys remember the hurtle game hell yeah
all stuff with the little turtle court
here yeah I remember the turdy turtle
work yeah you would give coordinates and
but you could pro is program
exercise but all I I never have ever
understood programming in my life
so all it was to me was a turtle game
where you tell this little turtle to go
all right go over halfway across the
screen little buddy and he does it but
he draws a line behind him yeah all
right now go down
mm-hm and then you would make like a
star in my case I would like make
pentagram oh of course no I remember
like I played that Earl game I played
math blaster and typing and there was
like these sick ass typing like Mavis
beat Isis yeah yeah I was maybe speak
maybe c-game's was not a real person
have you guys ever played the newspaper
what's the newspaper boy for the nes
that's the first game I play like that
should be a great smash fighter karma
yeah you know Jack if paper boy becomes
a smash fighter I think you should take
credit now you should be on the record
oh yeah what else will he be on yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah strong [ __ ] yeah I play
Mavis Beacon online maybe you know you
got their attention with that Ness video
so oh yeah they definitely wanna watch
me do you all watch that that video
sucks man but thank you you got like
like eight channels I could watch you
all want to step this podcast up and
watch me play Mavis Beacon live oh my
god [ __ ] you up all right thank you
yeah they turn into a crazy wait I'm
clicking start again or fires out of
five according to the rating that's
great
that's a that's a solid eight games have
to evacuate the house with that many
damn 1987 get back to the lesbians oh
yeah right remember waiting about not
snow look how low her blouse is that
girl's a straight-up guy shank like I
can I can almost see her cleavage no
joke is that they're not eggs yank you
know we got we get it thank you
the joke is there clearly yours might
not get it they clearly have too many
walls up
I think this necklace is way
to provocative and the fact that she's
drawing attention to her it's drawing
way too much attention to her beautiful
neckline and it's just frankly I'm
uncomfortable I'm and I'm getting a
little turned on and it's too much I
know you ever say what you know what
she's a dirty skank wearing a necklace
like that she's a nasty little hose
about to go kiss a lot this week I can't
wait for the verge calm disgusting
youtuber calls another beautiful
innocent youtuber besting you you hit
play and she's like so anyway my dad's a
lawyer h3 calls pure Christian girl ass
game right she's a skank no she's fine
okay I'm excited now but watch some
Christian authors and they were sharing
about how I feel bad making fun of these
girls you what oh yeah because like oh
man if only they had had a regular
upbringing up ring yeah I give you no
they wouldn't think of kissing as this
as there's something that we unholy
right right absolutely really cool and
now she does but Jesus Christ well you
see things what is cool wait a kiss yeah
waiting - yes okay okay that's two
different things kissing or waiting to
kiss is cool that's what he's excited
okay and that's fair and she never had a
summer as a world where you know we're
waiting to kiss like that's like Jesus
that's part of growing up your first
kiss when it's like you know you why
like that Boy Meets World episode yes
Cory up shoves him up against the locker
okay y'all know what I'm talking about
thank you no I
that episode it has right past those
amazing the way I want to say do you
remember your first kiss there yeah I do
it was at a summer camp mm-hmm tell me
about it give me the details I mean it
was it was like completely embarrassing
and weird and silly but like I was super
young and it was like all right got that
out of the way why was that weird
that's literally we're 25 that was yeah
it was just like what oh yeah I was 20 I
was a counselor I was super embarrassed
and I really I couldn't follow through
she was super I was like it was back
when I was she was into it and I must
have been like 12 that's you and I ran
away yes because I was too embarrassed
like a [ __ ] no I mean I [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of her
I remember that's that's no I liked her
that girl that I that I kissed it was
like okay we're girl girlfriend
boyfriend now no okay
and I was staying with my grandma to go
to this summer camp and I came home on
that bus from the summer camp and I was
like I have a girlfriend and then I came
home and I went to bed and woke up went
to [ __ ] summer camp the next day and
then like I didn't know what to do she
was like sitting over there and I was
sitting over here with my buddies and I
was like did I go over there and they
were like I don't know we were the ones
good at sports why the [ __ ] did you get
this and and then later in the day she
walked over with all of her friends and
she was like I decided we're not
boyfriend and girlfriend all right I
don't blame you it was fun yeah you got
yours baby I was like yo I got mine and
yeah like shades came out of the heavens
of course obviously deal with it yeah
did you guys do the heart necklace is
there like break into half no did you do
that with boys yeah you did that with
boys you never tell me that ela no it's
not gonna tell me that stuff itself yeah
don't let them know about our necklaces
it's like we someone would give it to
you and then you're like go find
boyfriend but it doesn't mean anything
like you know I know that was a thing
intangible weight indicating that you
are in fact offerings do you get half
hearts from multiple boys and what
happens if you get too many suitors it
wasn't anything like that
what was your first kiss so much right
now
Yeah right you don't remember your first
kiss everyone does that's what your
money meant to you oh come on she does
you just don't want to talk about it but
that's fine
I don't think I remember thank you okay
that's fine I'll tell you mine I got a
juicy one I was in I was a late bloomer
please please yeah let her let her let
her lap he can do ghost stories I was a
kid I was 16 and I liked a girl who had
a boyfriend
that wasn't me yeah it was juicy um but
she liked me kind of oh yeah she liked
me so what happened was we went to like
I went to her house but we went to like
she happened to have in her backyard she
had a Creek right and like whoo like
where this is going oh it was like in
the fall away yeah go to three and we
like wade into the creek a little bit
you know with like running water and you
know it's like a brook I don't know the
difference being a park in the creek but
it was did you relive this magical
moment it was the hottest moment of my
life man no so like and she had this
boyfriend but she was like all right
close your eyes and we kissed while we
were in this Brooks / oh that's a
beautiful magical thing and she was like
taken but she was my first kiss she was
taken but smitten
Oh aptly put my friend aptly put damn
you're [ __ ] pimp dude but like never
advanced beyond that so she stayed with
him yeah of course yeah I got caught
Emily but she was my first kiss so in
other words I got mine
oh wait was that what that must have
been tough for you it was it was that's
a that's emotion as a young man to my
[ __ ] teeth like that oh absolutely I
suffered immensely because like we both
clearly liked each other this girl and I
a nice car well he had a boyfriend Jimmy
she was kind of two-timing you know but
it's like you know it's that's the game
of love we all play the game of love you
just weren't equipped yet - I wasn't -
get it oh god I wasn't equipped for
anything I was 16 I was playing smash in
my basement you know like where is she
now she's still in that Creek son of a
[ __ ] I think she's doing that Creek I
think he was like Arthur's sword season
three of the first and last time pretty
executive she learned her [ __ ] lesson
wouldn't it be hilarious if the new
season of True detective aired and like
Jack is the murderer but he's he's like
legally yelling is there's an NDA where
he can't tell us so we were like doing
this podcast and like we're talking
about the new season of period that was
like joking like that totally crazy
right watch the last episode Jack's
little [ __ ] down by the creek I have my
first kiss I somehow gained like 50
pounds for the role yeah gained it it's
all 50 pounds of muscle what else we got
well speaking up hold on just going
backtracking a little bit because we
talked about the lovely bones a little
bit oh yeah
so Ryan Gosling of all people was
supposed to be the villain in The Lovely
Bones and he gained a significant amount
of weight he's supposed to be the
villain you're supposed to be the
villain he's about like the Martin about
know lovely bones it's about a girl who
gets like rapes and killed Oh
comedy oh and it's from her point of
view from like yeah you never see it but
like you get it and it's implied it's
very dark but like Ryan Gosling was
supposed to be that guy but Stanley
Tucci
I Stanley - she was the guy instead I'm
/ director but Ryan I'm so Ryan I'm
sorry the whole point is this was a this
was a TI Ellen right this was a today I
learned or movie details one of those
but like Ryan Gosling gained literally
30 to 50 pound he never did the part
they filmed it and Peter Jackson the
director didn't like he's like this guy
you imagine it's gonna go bad as imagine
as a [ __ ] actor you gained 30 to 50
that's like reshooting a YouTube video I
saw them I was like a [ __ ] YouTube
video it was just green screens [ __ ]
everywhere it was there was no I was
there for the scenes where they dumped
the where he dumps the body into the pit
yeah and the creek yeah or no just like
a big trash mole that they I know it's a
tired man like dumps her in a box into
the [ __ ] thing yeah I was there for
those days and for the neighborhood days
where oh sure there's a like in the
coldest sack of the neighborhood right
was like our burger kind of [ __ ] it was
like in Pennsylvania just the weirdest
really ya know I always forget you're
like is that your only boy your - place
to film the [ __ ] lovely bones I love
Philly I don't get why you don't love
Philly but so I brought me wrong yeah
it's not that I don't love it it's that
I'm done with it I mean it's a rough
it's kind of a rough place in it it's
the only place I've ever there Rockets
in it really you know if I get beat up
somewhere I'm gonna leave yeah you've
been beat up in Philly tell me yeah
what's it I think he told me your
neighbor here is there were her like
that's something I thought they were
pipes but while I was getting beat up
upon your internal infection they were
pieces of bicycle trash it's the older
bicyclist and then little his body like
the ball out like rebar
like pieces who use that to hit me a
bunch of times right before I was about
to move into this place and I was like
I'm just gonna move in there and I'm
gonna do it that's walk that you don't
want some pipe wielding little punks oh
sucked you gotta stay with yesterday
what that's nice time we go to Philly
man like it's a Phillies are great well
why do you go to Philly yeah I mean so
my so Aaron my wife is is from all right
you know like she well she's from a town
like just outside of I mean like she
spent a lot she's lived in fit like in
downtown Philly and early on like when
we just started dating in early 2013
I like lived with her in her apartment
in Philly for a month it was but it was
one of those things where I like I was
just gonna like hang out with her for
because she had come out to LA to like
visit me I hang out with me for a week
so I returned the favor the following
year in early 2013 to hang out with her
in Philly and it was just supposed to be
a week and then a week turned into two
weeks three weeks and then a whole month
over month but it's just it's a hell
it's just such a fun you walk everywhere
unlike LA you can't [ __ ] walk anywhere
in LA unless you're in downtown but no
one's in downtown you can walk anywhere
in Philadelphia it's a very walkable
city there's so much to do we went out
to dinner just about every single like a
different place every night cuz like
it's just there's so much to do in
Philly food doesn't seem to cross over
with your anecdote well I mean I I have
plenty of good things to say about
Philadelphia but they're all after I
left you like LA like we moved out of
there my parents moved us out of Philly
when I was 12 11 something like that cuz
uh a gangster got shot outside of our
house or a mobster it was terrifying
that's a like Italian mafia a rough
neighborhood no not at all but there was
FBI in some of the apartments that were
like oh [ __ ] watching us because at the
end of our block I grew up in at fifth
and Katherine in Philadelphia and there
was a takeover of the the mob scene at
the time this guy Joey Merlino
hmm and as I was a guy Ching golini and
Shing lien II had an older brother who
was with the current heads of the of the
mob and so these these younger boys put
out a hit on the older brother he got
shot went to a hospital the hospital was
where my father worked at the time and
these guys put the hit out from
apparently the end of the block where I
lived on so my dad's over here at this
hospital they bring in Ching Galini was
always like we're mobsters in the
hallway and [ __ ] and then meanwhile at
my house my mom has somebody like a
patient over that she's talking to and
so in retaliation for the hit to put
that guy in the hospital they come over
and just start firing at the guys at the
end of the block who by the way it used
to be a green piece and then this Junior
MAFIA took over and they turn into an
exterminators which is I think one of
the funniest reversals you guys a
classic comedy reversal right there so
anyway they shot the [ __ ] out of these
guys join me lino got shot in the ass a
bunch of people died on your street one
person died I think it was Ching
galini's brother this younger guy died
and then this is by the way I'm I'm not
a Wikipedia article for this so if I'm
wrong it doesn't make the whole thing
wrong yeah it just makes like that part
wrong so did it escalate the tingling
gay war no it was like pretty much over
that was that because it was just like
what the [ __ ] and then watch them as far
as like I was concerned or my family was
concerned because I think our house was
already on the market when that happened
but once that happened and really put a
fire under my parents ester like selling
after that happen I doubt it because it
was like now if you go to that
neighborhood it's beautiful right but at
the time it was just these these [ __ ]
got mooks here is that a word it is now
man he's got Mook silver on them to the
street ei get the [ __ ] exterminated
they're the ones getting exterminated I
realized how I don't know I realize how
good fella's Merlino isn't [ __ ] her
prison right now they found him
as as high-profile as this guy was by
the way he was like limping away with a
bullet in his ass and they found him
under someone's bed when they were
coming to arrest them remember that from
the news
oh they kicked someone's door in there's
this movie gonna be amazing you know
right I want to watch jingle Amy I mean
jingling key hey at least they didn't
fire his name gets more of it glad they
use bullets and not do that I want this
movie written from your perspective my
perspective would be like an
eight-year-old comes home and they're
loading a body into an ambulance and
they're girls like we still got a
Nintendo don't care at all yeah like the
worst movie ever
what's that nothing nothing get the
[ __ ] house right right what is that
looks like a dead body no no no no again
Sagan's I ever having I'm always amazed
looking back on on my capacity to not
give a [ __ ] when I was a kid yeah like
no matter what awful thing was happening
in the world I just didn't care at all
well your yeah your brains wired locally
you know we've pretty much reached the
end of our document no we've got hajiman
well we got on the pod youment yeah well
we've got bacon vending machine okay
okay we also have Eric reacts to YouTube
rewind I had a pitch for you guys yes
the rewind I would love to just get a
brief out there on I was making sure
that I wasn't getting a text message
from my dad being like don't talk about
that oh nice because I remember the last
time I was on he was like I remember
phones do we have notes we have notes
from our answer on my parents usually
they do have something to say every once
a while I have I don't have anything for
your parents however I do have a summary
of answers for all of the furry
questions we had earlier in the oh yes
how better had fun at the park were
there about an hour just returned from a
walk shredder poops I'm trying
feed him now do you guys use the app
that's really what's adding the dog walk
out my man I don't trust rain that's way
better
we love shredder tell me about the
furries if you would please okay so a
gentleman with a little furry avatar
named Dan reached out and Diane yep so
Dan just some real simple bullet-pointed
answers here's furries are like any
fandom the way I like to think about is
basically saying that furries are all
about sex is like saying everyone who
watches anime like hentai okay hold on
let me Twitter let me put a stop first
of all fandom of what I think his point
is saying that it's a it's a diverse
fandom there and then it's not a
monolith there are different sexes in it
if you will and so so is being a furry
putting on a suit like word is because
that seems like an extreme so where does
furry ism start I like yeah I think the
suit is a requirement I think that's
kind of the base that's that's that's an
extreme that's not like watching anime
that's getting in a suit and going
meeting people
well hold on he addresses that so and
again furry people I'm not I'm just I'm
trying to understand cuteness I carry it
it's a new furry people and I and I
don't want to be that just you aren't
but I do have a 250 IQ and I'm trying to
stress my massive intellect what's it
like up there that view
so go ahead please Dan so he says he
does agree many fur suits especially the
faces and eyes are definitely kind of
creepy or off in some way but they're
super expensive and the nicer they are
the pricier so I guess he's saying you
know the cheap ones are gonna look
creepier well I think I think it's just
an uncanny thing cuz it's like a fox
humanoid
uncanny valley yes but please Danny if
you kept sure and so he says on that
note since they're so expensive and hard
to clean most people who own them we
don't usually not have sex in them right
there are even some drama in the past
where people are saying that those who
do have sex in their suits shouldn't
wear them in public but who knows how
that argument ended so among how many
fake bunk how many fandoms are there
arguments amongst themselves about
wearing their suits having sex in their
suits like it's clearly a part of the
Quantic right in my suit it's definitely
an eye on that I'm suit I would want to
come it's a calm to spend all this money
on a suit well you're a footage do you
want to mark your territory so I got it
I think the anime comparison is apt in
that he's saying you know like myself
you know I enjoy anime but I'm not into
the hentai aspect of it which is sort of
like it's a subculture within a
subculture ok the people that are that
it's super sexual for within the Ferdie
community that's just one section ok you
know ok and so and then he says a bad
dress he this is a different person also
talked about bad dragon is basically a
website that makes weird sex toys mostly
marketed towards furries those wearable
things are basically like a dildo that
goes around your dick so there you go
so you don't get any well you don't get
any physical well I guess the person
wearing it does because the debts that
is wave [ __ ] nicer than your own
other if you want to you can get
electrodes does it well yeah I've got a
guy I got a prop thick that looks like a
creature from shape of water oh I just I
just shot myself in the deck with it on
and film it for fiber they don't
interestingly I've killed a couple
people with it and so the bad dragon is
a is a penis modification that looks
like an animal's well Bacchus is just a
website my website is sold various
different your own tiny little pathetic
human penis right but for those of you
at home that
dragon calm Pakistan will love that yeah
and then his final point here is that
not everyone who likes furries really
buys into the fandom some people really
live it like with any fandom but some
people just like it and don't really go
to conventions and let's do this I've
just what are they fans of dressing up
his animals yeah cosplay cosplay cosplay
what I'm missing is I feel like there's
an organ cozy play I think there's an
origin to this that we're not
understanding right now what's the
origin where does it come from there's
got to be its cosplay like how did they
decide that they loved dressing up like
foxes like what's the origin there's got
to be a show yeah it was yeah what's the
first piece of entertainment where the
main character was an animal
anthropomorphic yeah animal Fox Felix
the Cat it was a Winnie the Pooh and
just him walking around without no pants
Mickey did a lot of people were like yo
but I want I want to know the origin
that's the big well that's weird too
because you know the the furry thing
it's all animals but like it seems and I
could be wrong about this but it seems
like 80% of them foxes yeah it's all Fox
so there's something going on there well
foxes are sexy one of the sexier animals
yeah yeah you know like you look at uh
oh do you look at a fox and yeah try not
see it horn wait what's okay what's the
sexiest Fox though I'm the one from the
Fox and the hello me what am I thinking
of Disney yeah Fox was filed from smash
and I've seen that that's like one of
those old like from the 60s Animated
Classics of Disney at the Fox and the
Hound no I'm more of a [ __ ] and lady in
the trailer ladies yeah more of a I
don't think there are any foxes in that
movie I would come on the trip
we know you what the [ __ ] would is that
not like a skank
it you so it used to means something
different so so so um Charlie Chaplin
played the
the lovable [ __ ] like his character was
a [ __ ] and it was just kind of like it
meant something different back in the
day when I said back in the day I mean
like in look [ __ ] twenties thirties I
apologize if that's not quite the right
timeline but it used to mean something
so Lady and the [ __ ] did not mean like
because it was lady the lady dog and
then [ __ ] was like this homeless kind
of like that vagabond little guy yeah
yeah and so it meant something different
so today in today's standard you know
[ __ ] stamp that's obviously a
derogatory you know term for that Disney
making a movie called like lady in the
skank skank in a bottle yeah that's
gonna be their next CGI live-action
remake after Aladdin after Mulan well
I've got to know what's with the farm on
Wikipedia oh very I mean you can look it
up easily the furry fandom is a
subculture interested in anthropomorphic
animal characters with human
personalities and characteristics the
white box is you're right then they're
all foxes yeah mostly Fox the Fox thing
seems to that's the number one a foxes
is sexy yeah all right let's see we've
got we've got all of the good stuff oh
we never we never did watch the the
married that Mary Owens you'll [ __ ]
these skanks I want to pitch some tramps
yes these tramps they can go kick rocks
yes vetoing this you think that's a
dangerous watch no I'm just saying do
you think they do anal do you think they
do a not you there's a lot of credit and
there's a lot of religious girls who
don't have sex because it's forbidden
until they get married but they they
take it up the butt you guys heard about
smoking really yeah soaking what does
that mean oh please that is a Mormon
thing where before you're allowed to
actually have sex you can insert but
just leave it there what you can't go in
and out no I'm soaking wait you mean the
penis body
go Mormon so you talking about a penis
or a toy penis lucky this is in the
vagina but as long as you don't move
I'm into that but no no that's a short
calm down okay Google that Google's
soaking first of all there's no way that
you can soak and not end up [ __ ] so
there's okay there is the game's called
fear of God no yeah you guys know just a
tip yes yeah just a tip never ever ends
with the guy not coming like just the
tip is always like the guy yeah like hey
hey baby just a tip yeah and then they
like you know he's like just the tip
okay
I usually just 20% yeah anyway my dick
let's give a good right now right now I
wish we were watching that video was all
downhill that was the most entertaining
video of the night yeah well see we're
getting find new characters in 2019
Petey piranha plant is the number II
characters are they're like home launch
on launch there's like oh you only get
70 70 I think oh when you like no okay
okay you get eight and you have to
unlock the rest yeah in total at launch
there are over 70 there's like some more
that's gonna be like 100 [ __ ] 50 by
the oh wow that's a cray that fill that
bag up makes the cut everything that
would be a lot mark yeah what's the
subreddit for the for that because I'm
gonna have to filter it out because I
don't want to see a goddamn announcement
for a new character every two weeks
well you know well you're not seeing it
you ain't got a problem all right here
comes a hat
right he's just a hat you gotta be you
and be excited for a hat
new challenger right right right Newt
Gingrich oh my god I would play nice
Birds he's really trying to get in with
the kids I guess let's wrap it up as I
go
sorry it's been million dollar idea it's
been almost three hours but I'll take
the
let's let's make it to three I'm very
excited about this so you guys are
talking about the YouTube rewind I don't
give a [ __ ] about that
right the rewind itself but next year I
really want to see an h3 wined
h3 one where you hit up all your friends
like to me and then make the video that
everybody wanted to see why is YouTube
got to make the phone I don't think I'm
the guy for that finger on the pulse you
know what I mean well you got you got
people to help you out you got people
coordinated lady wined h3 wine I mean
the name is kind of too good to pass on
yeah it is a good idea it should be like
everyone who slipped up and said the N
word make it
ian's and I'll do a quick roll Instagram
and PewDiePie and more compilation yes
h3 wine n-word comp h3 wined I just I'm
just saying okay I want to put it out
there think about it Jack looks like he
wants to make that n-word cut right now
[Music]
I'm sober dan no I think that's a great
idea
h3 wine 2019 YouTube can make whatever
they want
mm-hmm they're gonna make some weird
that's a really caters to a certain
demographic that they're happy about
your through isn't always at the same
date I think so yeah
I'm always surprised when it comes out
yeah I didn't but I think there there's
got to be some method to the here's
here's my reason for wanting this is
that like so many people seem to give a
[ __ ] right yeah
why do you why do you honestly [ __ ]
care what this website makes I'll tell
you why I'll tell you exactly why
because it affects us all Eric okay and
if it looks bad to one it looks bad to
all of us no it's it's a lot of like was
a 10 million dislikes or whatever that's
exactly what I did to a meme really
it wasn't mean to dislike it let them
make whatever the hell they want but I
think the it's hard not to care I don't
know why it's just the the the
burden with making a good one should not
be on them because clearly they're not
going they drop the ball the burden of
making the going shitty on you it
requires a lot of resources a lot of
coordinating that ya do I can't get like
I can't get you could do it year-round
year-round anytime you get a guest on
the podcast get there so that I'm gonna
veto that it's gotta be at the end of
the year yeah I'm sorry
like I see what you're going but it's
gotta be like a lot and you all think
and and I'm just I think to mate I just
you know I don't it's a lot of
responsibility Eric and I'm really
stressed out already just thinking about
I guarantee I mean I'm not I'm not the
say all be all or anything like that go
let's make a poll okay you make the
rewind let's take a poll all right but I
don't have a catchy name for it it's the
it's the YouTube the h3 wind rolls right
off the tongue it really does it really
does
h3 the threes even like a backwards e
we're gonna think of one it's the key
wine he wine baby do the h3 one I wish I
could yeah - yeah what would yours be it
would start with Will Smith hell yeah
version of him and then like melting
puddle and then in the puddle you see
the planet nibiru coming around the Sun
then it so all up all the oceans of
Earth you have this this is totally
off-the-cuff and then and then what
happens is Steve Bannon is riding one of
those waves up towards the Sun and he
turns to the camera and he says
something incredibly hateful but
poignant yeah everyone agrees with he
just drops the Emma with a hearty are
drops of Laurie are blowin and ends
purposeful and then like a check gets
shot at him and he catches it right
before it kills him
like deck hmm and he slowly inserts it
in his ass and you see it close-up I'm
just saying it 2019 you guys we're
getting the Suzanne three hours and that
Susan comes out and says now that's a
rewind yeah damn good just cut it off
yeah yeah damn it dance with me by the
way he's been hitting me up on our
little office cat stop us wrap it up he
goes let's wrap it up
well our live look at he's again we're
getting Henny right hashtag H three ones
everybody spin me none shall be forced
to there's really no choice here do you
think Will Smith will do everyone for me
I think Mike will just give me one of
these scribing it as that I don't know
if that's entirely insensitive thanks no
thanks I think he goes like I know I
think like I think it's like a R&B
hip-hop like old-school RPA nobody's
trying so hard not to act because like I
said this is the this is the performance
of his career because nobody has had to
try to pretend to like fortnight and
YouTube as much as Will Smith that he
doesn't yeah his opening line is I want
fortnight and Marquis Brown so you do
know you do know who you're [ __ ] like
yeah watch the first 20 seconds yeah and
then I
I'm 30 why just love you that's by the
way they promote it it's like everywhere
oh it's they like knock their heads no
they cheat there yes absolutely you know
they shot that [ __ ] with Marquis Brown
in the bus before the got Will Smith
because he just looks into the camera
he's like is this what you wanted
yes all I can think about is like
alright whoever we get you're gonna say
I want fortnight or can't Anna hug you I
don't know I just don't know about this
one ah he directed everyone most like
the goat who sounds like a man sound
yeah I know that yeah yeah yeah you
think he's mad that they didn't give him
like proper direction like like do you
think he had final approval over this or
did up in there at least right oh no
Will Smith probably [ __ ] did he
probably cuz if I will Smith Oh Billy we
gotta be a part of it I think he's legit
happy to be a part of free wine because
like he I checked his channel out and he
is like legit trying to delve into the
YouTube world and I think like just any
involvement I mean that any involvement
in rewind he is very happy to get I
agree like he's in his in his channel
trailer he sounds like YouTube has
reinvigorated me it's given and to be
fair I think that's [ __ ] cool like I
mean yeah one hand it's like it's an
a-list a triple haleyss dude Hollywood
star getting into you too but on the
other hand like if it gets them excited
like I can't afford something for as
long as they don't put an ad for sell
allergy exactly dogs in a Volvo
Dianetics yeah I'm raising my kids in a
cryo chamber I probably being a on
YouTube yeah at all I mean for us
of course yeah but like people said like
making [ __ ] was it last year was it the
rock it was the 1 or 2 years ago was the
rock I forget which one like he opens a
fan by the way how active is the rock
like that was a good bet once he never
knew right right you never knew it yeah
where's not but like will actual rewind
I would want fortnight I also the
premise of this videos exactly that's a
dab of a moment absolutely but the
premise is like that Will Smith is in
charge of rewind it's like it's all you
baby you're the one you're neo
yeah that wasn't the best cure to make
it yeah it's like whoever watches us put
will in charge to rewind yeah it's like
a [ __ ] fever dream like he drops
Aston and hallucinates it should but
little dude from the bag man thing yeah
bad [ __ ] if I was a control everyone I
would be bad that [ __ ] and the Christian
girls do anal yeah look I don't know
what you guys have against dude the
rewind would be fun that's amazing let's
h three wind this podcast please but
only after this he's talking to well
it's like yeah what are we all just
singing and dancing try to impress Will
Smith is this what you wanted well
apparently according to marques Brownlee
he they shot like hours of footage for
this but of course you only see like
mere seconds so they I think they had a
lot of different options
were you in last year's I was in like we
were in the dance scene right yeah hey
there was like a a second of you did you
know going in that was two years two
years ago there was like a frame of me
yeah last year there was a slight smidge
more I think you remember seeing two
years ago I do not know I would be like
that cut out of it two years ago I don't
know if I can clue I know it's just one
of those like you're there all day make
the most of it and you hope and you pray
that now some smidge of you makes it
into the final cut that's all it is and
they never guarantee it until like the
day of [ __ ] comes out well because
they have editors and they have notes
they have producers there's so many and
different things away and get it
they're very brand focused with this
whole thing the entire thing is an
advertisement it is to advertisers it's
how how safe we are healing we are gonna
make it there like oh my god Will Smith
my buddy
exactly and so like yeah everyone myself
included made fun of YouTube rewind for
like Oh Will Smith he's my favorite
youtuber pause for laughter but at the
same time it's very appealing to see
this Triple A lister Hollywood star in
this thing because that's all it is
yeah it's an it's an advertisement and I
can't fault YouTube are you a reporter
late for that I mean they got to do what
they got to do and that's all I'm and
and well as long as people don't expect
anything better right I feel like they
have a scene about a crazy person
because this thing came out and
everybody hated and I was like wait you
shocked
you [ __ ] surprised this well well
well that's because these two pointed
out in your excellent recap video that
YouTube rewind wasn't always this
totally hateable thing in fact it used
to be quite likeable and loved it it's
funny that I'm diving into being a
complete [ __ ] here because it's just
you being [ __ ] ignorant that's what
I've always been in a [ __ ] apk EPK
was an electronic press kit thing it's
just the [ __ ] way to show you yours
right you've been on set before it's
it's nonsense
it's a [ __ ] nonsense thing you watch
it and you're not investor wasting well
like there yeah they got everybody but
but they didn't though they didn't get a
lot of people that's it's not like funny
or entertaining they didn't get a lot of
city players that like so shane dawson
for example like he is like like him or
not he was a huge part of youtube this
year a lot of people yeah and a lot of
you a lot of people i think next year is
gonna be awesome because they've got
nothing to lose i think next year's
gonna rock more it's gonna be Susan on
her back
taking a giant check mark in the ass and
being like is this what you wanted
super close-up hairy [ __ ] cuz she's a
MILF right she's in the middle dad and I
said cut it he's in the milk category
we're starting there we go and then it's
just her I'd like to apologize for
everything so is this which will start
with Will Smith trying to drown his
start Will Smith and he goes no I
controlled rewind it would be Susan
Wojcicki on her back taking it up the
ass with the bear bite she would be like
a human is this what you wanted we'll
all right guys thanks for watching lobby
mom - next Tuesday we got a charity
stream and a floppy mom yeah next week
on Tuesday days gonna be huge it's me
one of our biggest last year we raised
240,000 this year we're gonna top it
because we've got tons of amazing stuff
to give away
we've got Joey salads back in the studio
to torture for our amusement we've got
so much amazing stuff written and Morty
exclusive merch h3 historical merch and
if you play your cards right you might
see Susan Wojcicki I'm just kidding
nobody wants to you know yeah love Susan
she tries her best she's good at her
she's really great
is the music music playing yep okay so
that wraps this concludes this episode
of the boys are back in town
Jack the film's the legend thank you so
much I wish you well
just keep working man don't just keep
just keep grinding - hey you're gonna
work your way to the rut it's inevitable
you know what I'm saying hey baby boy
yeah shoot - the both of you and to you
as well but you don't need my help
Hey
thank you so much make a video every
once in awhile I'll be happy don't know
more once a month is good yeah thank you
once a week 20 19 you alright
we've got two more episodes this year so
you don't you won't want to miss it the
hangar aid just like thanks for watching
don't wanna miss you babe don't
cooperate the song and I all right just